two hello everybody it is I Ethan Klein
host of the H3
podcast he's
up I am up like Jesus on
Easter yeah and we know how up that is
that's up as it
gets yes it is November
8th thank you guys for being here he's
that's slide no you know what nothing
says Jesus Christ has risen again like a
slide
whistle I think the Christians would
would appreciate that
sentiment uh we love the Christians
though don't we folks we love them and
we kid them uh those Italians I love the
Italians we sure
do uh today's November 8th it's
Wednesday it's off the rails I'm still
feeling kind of sick so I'm going to
talk I'm trying to trying not to project
too much because yesterday on the
members live it was kind of horse uh
situation for me
and what I can't hear you you've got to
project oh come on it's not funny huh
come on I'm going through enough don't
don't tease me
sorry Ethan what story in my
life what
exactly nice God damn this thing is
troopy Dan it's like can't keep it up
pills for that yeah I he's up but he's
not anyway guys we have tons of fun
stuff to um get to today including more
chocolate and but don't worry it's not
like a whole thing if you care but we
just heard that
Tony
who's ke let me get a different Tony
yeah and Tony apparently Tony is the
king of fair trade ethical chocolate
which has been you know a big part of
the conversation we've been having with
uh our our chocolateers what are you
afraid
of um this is a fat bar too boy
and I'm assuming that the the milka came
from you love this is I know like a
European Delight didn't but it might
could have been cuz I do like that shock
but it's very European it's a nice tree
brought that one too it's a nice treat M
so I'm going to try him probably going
to like him I am curious about Tony
though what's Tony doing what's how's
Tony do this stuff you know Tony Brown
what are you afraid of does freedom
taste better I think it does probably
we'll
see
um
we've got all kinds of fun stuff to talk
about you seen in the title we got the
Boogie
documentary so many great moments in
that I I'm looking forward to sharing
with you guys we've got the uh oh this
guy we watched who was he's yelling and
harassing Scientologist in Hollywood
he's calling
in at 2
p.m a local
hero and uh other other fun stuff you
know what I mean
but but you know at the top of the show
I want to say a few things here because
we don't have sponsors obviously why
would we so I want to say first of all
thank you to our members who support us
during these trying trying times oh yeah
I want to give a shout out to the teddy
fresh new collection this is shirt is
sick I haven't I didn't actually even
know I just saw it for the first time
it's Captain Planet saying
what does it say that place say that
place is and he's got he's
smoking a cigarette sick I'm not long
for this planet can you um ony
it there is only one
key okay there's only one
key oh that's uh jigsaw
I was wondering who that
is um also excuse
me we also have uh the Black Friday sale
is tomorrow again I am out of the
loop I don't know what's going on Black
Friday is what tomorrow it's not even
close but tomorrow is the Black Friday
sale it is it is both not Friday and not
Black Friday
Friday but uh
regardless we're moving forward
regardless we got it wrong on the
calendar and we're not making any
changes tomorrow is the Black Friday
sale
um I don't have any interesting media to
even share with you guys either so you
just have to take my word for it you
know use your imagination just think
about what you could look like here
here's Oney fresh it's up to 60% off you
guys know we always hard as on our
60 up to 60% yeah you couldn't even get
Jonathan to do 22 that's what I'm saying
this man couldn't you know like come on
bro sorry I don't want to give him
you got enough
damn it I guess here here's a video
Let's see is
there probably probably I'm not even
going to play the
music uh who has the black best Black
Friday sale is Teddy fresh made by
bears no is Teddy fresh Black Friday
sale this year I'll I'll I'll just tell
you guys I'll ruin the uh surprise hold
on yeah tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. PST up to
60% off you guys know it always goes
crazy hard on that day so see you
there see you
there also exciting to announce our
annual trading cards I have a arrived
are these going on sale now on sale now
oh they're already on sale
okay so this is a tradition we've been
doing annually now this would be our
third
year
um last year we had the golden prolapse
which was very very exciting as a
collectible this year we have Ethan's
credit
card and this is a
Bonafide these are the real digits got a
real barcode you can use this you can go
to APM and buy yourself a sodi right now
to me Dam it so a thousand lucky
orders will be getting one of
these here's the pack let me look at the
gallery because obviously we'll see him
better now the theme of this year's pack
was that each person made their own card
yeah uhhuh and you know the and the
continuing theme of a lot of help from
cam not me you did it all 100% Your Own
100% myself right some people
understandably were like I can't do
Photoshop right which I get but
conceptually everybody came up with
their own yes
yeah um continuing with the theme of
artistic expression that we've been
doing this year we said let's go do it
on the cards Let's Take a Look by the
way worth noting 100% of all of the
profits from
this SL Revenue will be going to the
crew I will not be taking a dime your
card a little bit isn't it and it is my
card and that's you know the that's the
kind of boss I am to you guys not only
am I not taking
cut I'm sending wow Untold Untold vast
amounts of
money to a thousand of you guys redistri
King right here so support the crew and
also get yourself some great uh
cards here's take a look so there's two
different cards one that you can buy now
that we have in stock and then some that
if it goes over the at total amount we
have it will go to a pre-order this is
just so that everyone can get one that
wants to basically there are slightly
different cards in the two packs though
I will and they're also all available
now and they're all available now are
going to ship in January so these red
ones are going to ship immediately
they'll when when people people can
expect them when uh before Christmas
before Christmas for sure early December
Y and then these ones will come in
January you said yep okay so there you
go uh there's different cards in each
pack um as I'll show you guys so let's
take a look at the Green pack yeah the
Green pack has these special exclusive
shiny art cards
featuring Ethan by Dan Ethan by Olivia
Ethan by Ela Ethan by Cameron and Ethan
by Zach
beautiful and then in the red one you
get the Ethan by AB by Ian by Sam by
Lena and by somebody whose name was
filtered out me AB right no I love but
thank you
oh I feel you got slided here love do
you
agree I mean we're getting all the
profits I don't know yeah whatever no
complain also a thousand random people
and this will be in both pack um both
packs will have an opportunity to get
the credit card or just the the I think
just the first pack the first one mhm so
that oh is that wrong we're both packs
are going to have the credit yeah we're
going to we're going to it's going to be
spread out 500 of the red pack orders
and 500 of the Green pack orders don't
have to worry and if you buy the red
pack and the Green pack I'm gonna ship
the red pack out early so you're gonna
get it in December and then you'll get
your Green pack later now again uh
listen you you don't have to buy both
packs just for the record it's just
there's five different ones in each pack
just to uh a little treasure there for
you guys so this is the one I made and
this might look simple to you but I
promise this took me like 5
hours it's still real to me damage I did
capitalism I I created this basically
right after the socialism capitalism
debate we had here it's got unlimited
health livable wage uh here's my attack
your boss is one of the good guys he
might be a capitalist but he loves the
working class you have a wage high
enough to pay your rent health insurance
car payments and food wow and here and
here wow here's a picture of the
generous Capital
owner sharing the
world moving on here's scientist
[Applause]
Ela stist stomp yeah that's good that's
good get stomped um number W this one
turned out really good Dan thank you
thank you great job Dan cam helped with
this I mean Dan took the photos I did I
had the concept uh cam had the execution
I actually took the photo but it's all
good oh okay Dan did nothing yeah I
stood there it turned out really good
though yeah w w w
Dan Olivia just precious as you would
expect rainbow stars flow it's happening
it's it is happening literally thank you
Max for helping me
oh Zack the sound lad in space wow the
master of shred that one's special that
one is beautiful I uh just want to say I
designed that all by myself yeah hey
made that yes in a program that yeah in
canvas so I had to go through I had to
export everything separately ex he's the
goat that's why he's the goat he's the
goat he goes his own way I think L yeah
I guess it's too late but live at the
Roxy would have been pretty cool too I
was floating around with some ideas but
I wanted it to be kind of like a action
figure like old 70s Star Wars it I like
it definitely give him Star Wars yeah he
he's bigger than the rocky now he sold
out I mean he was at the bowl so yeah I
guess what I mean is you missed the
opportunity to promote your next show
oh that that would have been interesting
that's how he got so good at ca he was
making all of his promotions there yeah
oh this one is so good Ian two
wolves um yes I did I designed this one
myself as well this is a really
beautiful card frankly uh comedy aside
aesthetically very pleasing to look at
thank you it's a strong card for sure
absolutely Sam in the gecko curse
awesome terrified quisine oh my God and
she is the queen of Cur
Cuisine AB uh he has unknown Health
savior of babies and pregnant women
destroyer of doors loser of boxing
matches oh yeah let's
go Cameron is bird
brain what's the
777777 HP I just like seven I don't know
okay I do too and I did seven sevens on
understood
understood um fat love this is so funny
first time at dennyland dyland
dyland
love did we talk about
how people were
like trying to defend you against fat
shamie Yeah you mentioned it on uh s so
people are yeah people were like can you
guys please stop being rude like is
nobody noticing the crazy fat shaming
going on with love people are which is I
appreciate it's sweet but it's a he's
not this isn't what he looks like not
that there's anything wrong with being
fat I'm getting there but not yet not
yet and I I guess I apparently spell
defense wrong and I said it dude
leave it in that's love core there is so
authentic of wait what did you misspell
defense like the right below my hand oh
defense got it appar there not SP like
that first time at
dennyland oops uh up next we have Lena
the
um the assistant extraordinaire
executive assistant
extraordinaire she's got so many arms
she's got so many ways I mean look at
this she really is something thank you
Lena thank
you okay distraction this is just a kind
of out there card you know
it's an instant you know or maybe it's a
sorcery card actually yeah Ethan by AB
Ethan by Ian Ethan by
love Ethan by Sam Ethan by Lena this is
a blank one I guess for your own
creation is that yeah make your own oh
right and there's there's another little
bonus that we're going to do uh Max
brought us all these blank cards and
passed them out to everybody on the crew
and gave us a Sharpie and we're all
going to Doodle something today on these
and these will also randomly be sent to
uh people that order today people that
order today specifically also I I'm the
guy that made the cards I yeah this is
Max people who don't
know so that's it so um Castle this is
on H3 shop.com is that right no it's on
TRD ng. shop trading. shop it's in the
uh description and it's on iined uh a
comment or a trading. shop we also have
a tiny tiny tiny bit of these available
the second pack we just had a couple
left over oh nice those are going to go
in like a second um and they're
available now there it is so my friends
it is time that time of year oh I'm so
oh look at us we got the whole hero uh
landing page love it oh yeah look at us
so this wait we do have one other thing
once again the quality of these cards
are fantastic I mean you've seen them in
previous years what Dan I just remember
we have have one other thing to show
what's that we made a little ad for
these right um and if that wasn't enough
to convince you we have a special
message from the
crew I remember the
laughs the lifelong
friends
the
games the puking the chewing into the
[Music]
microphone the
tears the bomb threats the feuds the
peace the
love the W's and the
L's the
cancellations the
triumphs
remember
[Music]
remember the good
times H3 podcast trading cards out
now that made that yeah that made me
emotional I frankly was
really kind of heartbroken by the end
just realizing that like one day wow
we're all this this place is going to be
over the lights are going to turn off
everyone's going to go their own way
from dust to dust Dan's going to be all
things all things must end hopefully in
a long time but still in a Time sooner
than you think so buy some cards now to
remember it buy some
cards I love how you guys get so
activated on this project for some
reason it's like you guys care so much
about this one it's nice to see it is
strange yeah also the the green packs
they're on sale until December 1st so
it's like an uncap pre-order the red
ones we only have 5,000 of them and
we're expecting them to sell out pretty
quickly well we'll see you know don't
don't count your eggs before they hatch
there well or or order now order now
yeah
yeah never make predictions n oh yeah uh
shout out to oliv I already see people
saying that asking about the makeup
Olivia did the makeup oh my God it was
so goodi me thank you it was literally
so good oh thank you I did a stage like
feeder makeup class in college so I I
tried my best on sale and I thought Ela
said the same thing I thought it was
like a uh AI yo an AI remix thank you
well that photo uh that Ian you took
that right it's like the uh the new
iPhone makes everything look so damn
good that's true thank you Steve Jobs
than Stevie thanks Stevie you made our
movie so good we love you you guys may
not know but that was a parody of the
David do dispo ad uh the app that is
doing really
well I don't know if you guys been
following but it has a ton of users on
it and I actually just wanted to watch
this cuz I forgot kind of what this is
all about let's
see is this a claim is this a I think it
flame a ad you monsters I I can
mute it so we don't you did is it you
think it's just the music it might just
be the music yeah all right I'll mute it
play the silly sex
music Let me just get a taste of
it you know what this is so unfair David
how are you going to actually like try
to cuz doing it as a parody I can see
how manipulative it is cuz it made me
sad
that and here's David remember the good
times
huh you remember our parody that we made
of
this made an edit where he replaced all
the photos with Jeff's Hospital
photos wait I want to watch that it was
it was years ago now I'll see if I can
find it somewh yeah I don't remember
that you remember that that's a funny
funny edit it was before my time
actually David do is never going to
maybe it was maybe it wasn't Kim maybe
it was somebody on the subreddit did
that he's still doing the tongue thing
after all these years
yeah HH I hate it makes me so
uncomfortable but there it is I think he
sold it for a nice little token probably
yeah I think he did sell it yeah you
know I'm not sure because he is
cancellation
coincided can we fact check that oh
Venture spark Capital decides to sever
all ties with David Do's dispo apps week
after leading deal oh he might have got
on it I think it may have just
like crashed totally and utterly cuz he
was about to get paid from that like
paid paid
yeah that niat
money niat got 20 million for his I
think David was pushing well above that
yeah so anyway that's all the that's
stuff happening there wait he sold it
for 25 million May Casey yeah oh he sold
it for
25 good for you cas
and also I'll say beam also doing very
well
now all of these Creator apps in general
are just doing phenomenally out there
and well worth the the price 25 million
I'm sure CNN doesn't regret that at all
yeah
25 you
you um so yeah one call to action dream
nightmare remix the deadline is today
yeah
so people at home who are working get it
in by the end of the day today so we can
start sorting through them Friday is
going to be phenomenal there are so so
many good
submissions I truly believe
[Music]
that I I'm going to try to convince
dream to like do official collab with
the winner to like officially license
the song that' be cool could be a bside
on the single
I mean it's like a remix and let's be
real the these ones are way better than
his and I don't and I say that with
peace and love he said the same
thing his voice is beautiful the
music you
know I don't
know here's uh here's our dubri uh
parody let's
[Music]
see oh so he's so sad cuz he's old and
he's got such great memor this is our
music right Zach I believe so yes now
funnily enough so who made this if it we
made it it's Seth what yeah I remember
this Seth was getting he's looking at
pictures of Seth and a gorilla that's
up and Jason and like blackface
what the hell that's not cool at
all these are the memories you cherish
David after all these years oh my
God
[Music]
these are the photos you saved of
everything Trisha crying and you bowling
big
Nick oh my goodness we see what happened
as a result of the he bullied big Nick
and look what look what happened
created a super
[Applause]
villain we made some good stuff I'll
tell you you go back oh my God what
happened to me oh my God noodle
hair you got I used tell you you go back
there's some good stuff out there I'll
tell you we're working out
here so that's
everything
um we have all kind Where Do We Begin I
kind of want to try some of this
chocolate I don't well our uh Our Guest
is going to be calling in in about uh 15
minutes so I'm just a little hungry do
you want to order
food I think it's too early for
that this one sounds crazy Tony's
chocolate
CH chocolate only CH chocol lonely
chocol lonely why lonely this says milk
chocolate Caramel Pretzel almond nougat
and sea salt Count Me In dude so people
know about Tony's this is apparently a
delicate tessent this is a I'm in a sea
of of people that know about chocolate
that know about Tony's hey Tony I'm
making chocolate over
here fair trade slavery free you think
Tony knows the the MS boss this is so
good you get
together this is I love this this is
like I'm not a bar person but this is
the type of bar I like G this Glo core m
m those ingredients are so good Caramel
Pretzel almond nougat that's like all
the stuff I
like wrapped into one
Tony Tony come on who you kidding huh
Tony all right one more bite and then
I'll get out of
this WOW any want to try this I I
need to try that
okay I can't eat any more chocolate man
I'm having trouble too I have a lot at
home now I think even Halloween just
happened too so we got leftover trick-or
treat candy I I think I may have ruined
chocolate for myself for a little while
yeah I
mean go ahead Queen you seem to be
loving that Tony bar I did I did love
that I can't eat chocolate I can't eat
more than that though I feel like my my
limit is very Tony chocolate's number
one hater is in the chat there's one
person who's all caps is their name
screaming Tony I hate this
candy I see you out there oh there upset
wait chill chill wait why are they so
upset just
Tony uh here it's moving really fast
what could you say about Tony I hate
Tony's all caps I thought it tastes
great
wow you know I've been kind of sour out
here cuz in my opinion European
chocolate is really much better than
American one but this is probably one of
the better on that's more European style
yeah this is milky creamy wow that's
really good oh here's cookie I'm GNA try
the cookie one I think I'm with the
Ethan I'm chocolate out you don't want
to try the Tony I've had so much
chocolate in the yeah dude yesterday I
was eating one of the bars that we have
on the counter and I felt something
crunchy and the remainder of my crown
fell out was a nougat uh no it was my
tooth yeah your tooth broke eating
chocolate yeah whose chocolate was that
uh the second one part uh compartes yeah
compartes dude I you want some
what the
I it's not their fault it was
already chipped are you sure how do you
know I don't know let's see what kind of
offer they make it it's not your fault
is that your actual tooth or a crown I
thought it was my actual tooth but
Dennis tell me it was a crown yeah
that's better yeah well yeah to replace
it though cuz it keeps falling out cuz
my actual tooth is so tiny it's like
over three grand which is
insane uh people are correcting us uh
love Tony's is actually it tastes
European because it is it is oh look at
that it's made in I think it said
Belgium I'm trying to find yeah Belgium
that's a B I thought I was going to be
nice to the Americans for once but I
guess that isn't the the Belgium they
got the way with the chocolate yeah they
do made in Belgium with cocoa butter
from the Ivory Coast how much is a bar
this and I want to I need to emphasize
how fat this bar is like you
could use this as a weapon uh where I
got it it was
$5.99 that's a good price for this much
chocolate and that's after being
imported that looks like a movie Willie
Wonka bar that's exactly what I was
thinking it looks just like like the
movie Wonka bar amazing oh
God I think actually I did a I had a
write up here cuz I'm real Curious so
many people are invested in the
chocolate slave industry so I wanted to
learn about it uh many cocoa farmers in
West West Africa Source around 70% of
the world's cocoa and they engage in
human trafficking child labor and child
slavery are you serious
colonialism baby here to stay wait they
traffic and put kids into slavery to
farm chocolate Coco
Jesus y' it's not good and you think
that like Hershey and these big
companies use that well Nestle was
famously like in a big lawsuit about
that that I think went to the Supreme
Court it's crazy cuz they they bribe
them with chocolate at first to get them
there and then they're part of the the
trade Farmers Only earned 6.6% of the
price of a chocolate bar and many of
themselves are living in
poverty six uh malians brought suit
against Nestle and
Cargill is that the the who's
Cargill it's probably one one of those
big uh I can't eat more I'm literally
take it away I'm Carill uh Global Food
Agriculture and bioindustrial
Specialists it's just a big like a
company it's big a so um they sued
them alleging that they had been
enslaving children at cocoa
plantations they describe working hours
without pay suffering hunger hazardous
working condition and brutal beatings
what the
the companies won the battle in court
but not the wider War they were waging
the court deemed the connection between
these companies in the particular labor
labor is too tenuous but it did affirm
that companies can still be held liable
for such abuses under the ATS statute I
don't know what ATS
is R doll tried to warn us dude he he
couched it in a Children's Fantasy but
he was trying to to point out those
Oompa loomas and then so if you looking
at um the ATS grants Federal
jurisdiction over any civil action where
an alien sues for a
Tor got it I like
torts you like torch isn't that a
Mexican sandwich tort are you thinking
tort torts I call them torts okay
[Laughter]
delicious I'm a fan of Tor I got sued
for torous interference I said I like
Tor I was going to say what is what is
tort oh you a Tor it's like a it's a
Mexican sandwich in Swedish torta is
cake the word oh really yeah I like it's
essentially like every Mexican food is
like the same five ingredients so it's
this but in a sandwich very good it's it
people like it I mean refers to flash
that one of all the Mexican items you'll
see on the menu seems to be of one of
the more authentic items and in terms of
what you might find in Mexico okay
interesting so here's what Tony does
differently um a chocolate love affair
Ben and Jerry has joined oh wait no
sorry that was a collab with Ben and
Jerry I'm not reading
that says hi there we're Tony's
chocolate choco lonely we exist in
exploitation in the cocoa industry our
vision is chocolate that is 100% free
from
exploitation not just our chocolate but
all chocolate worldwide the more people
join us and share our story The sooner
our vision can become the
norm the chocolate is yours are you in
most
impressively is that this cost six bucks
I mean that tells me that people who are
not
using like uh ethical chocolate or it's
not because of the
margins cuz six bucks is really
good it's made in Belgium it's shipped
out here you know what I
mean huh okay we like Tony why do you
keep saying Belgian do Belgian on the
packaging everybody in the chat kept
saying it was Dutch it's made in Belgium
it literally says Made in Belgium okay
well there you go chat's wrong I mean
Dutch well close next to each other yeah
it literally I'm literally looking at it
it says Belgium b e l g i u m
Belgium take the
L that's spells
Belgium right b e l g i u
[Music]
m I got to make sure because you never
know sound it out all right so there you
go AB what happened with your
tooth though yeah I don't know I just my
actual tooth is so tiny that it's hard
for the crown to grip onto it so this is
like the Lena's laughing this like the
third time it's cracked why is it funny
Lena I don't know it just is it happened
before before and he he walks around
with this tooth and I'm like what are
you doing with it he keeps it in his
pocket I don't know in case they need it
but they they said it was already too
far gone wait is it in your pocket now
no it's under my pillow nice Ni no I
don't have it so you want some I
like that joke thank you absolutely uh
Ashley says the most dangerous raw
material to get is palm oil lots of
people die from that
interesting tell me more about foods
that I need not
eat
um child slavery I mean that's almost
like too vile to even
believe like we're going to steal kids
and force them into chocolate slavery
what the show
us it's kind of cursed like this this
Timeless wholesome treat of chocolate is
being made with tiny little
hands forced in
slavery it's not right and that's why I
like Tony
thank you
Tony please get this out life I don't
want to ever eat chocolate
again it is really good
though so are there any other companies
that do the ethical I know and Bros says
on their website they do e yeah they
they say they Source from Jeff from
Andros oh yeah Jeff which by the way you
you're saying you're so sick of
chocolate yesterday you were demanding I
get you some more Ambrose I want that
well it's on its way is it coming today
uh I don't know I think we're going to
have to go pick it up from their um from
their Factory from their Chocolate
Factory which will be cool to see I yeah
I demanded more I like the ambros I'll
eat more of that that shit's crazy
I feel
you I feel you so there you go there you
go so much to learn in this world huh
um let's catch up on the Scientology guy
cuz he's going to be calling in here
pretty shortly yeah let's see in fact
I'll uh start getting that ready so this
guy is his Tik Tok account streets La we
watched him before and he is really
something he gets in the face of these
scientologists and he is fearless man
and then something else that I learned
about him he's also the guy we've
learned about this separately that it
gets in beefs with the food delivery
robots he's the same
guy in fact I've even seen videos where
they the two merge where there's
Scientology and food delivery in the
same video right outside the food
delivery spot well makes I mean both
they're both very Hollywood things you
know sure it's all
overlapping see now I'm Hest all I see
on his page right now is Scientology
stuff I'm looking for Rob robot stuff oh
it's a different account uh I believe he
posted to a his own it's called film the
robots oh you got to here lower
down in the dock um here I just
highlighted these are all uh robot stuff
oh that's you got to combine man we need
to appreciate your whole body of work
but here fil film the robots is doing
quite well here almost half a million
followers here's one the 7
million oh God careful um the next video
don't scroll to the next video what's in
it uh some homeless lady's uh be ass
okay yeah not this one not this one
thank
you God damn it sound look it is watch
this dude you got to love uh you got to
love
people oh he's steing panicking holy
he stole the food he's try to close
it again just leave bro what are you
trying to
do why you don't stick around the scene
of the I've never seen going off like
[Music]
that I got to love people are just like
I'm going to tip this thing for
no
reason and steal the food out of it I
get you get it yeah they kind of ask him
for it they're idiots it's like
are we really trying to take jobs away
from you know the one job that people
can get out there and do which is like
the Uber Eats they're trying to take put
that in the robots and not only
that to occupy our small walking spaces
in this city yeah the sidewalk real
estate is valuable and these robots are
thick boys yeah and they're like dumb
they're always getting in the way like
they're just they're annoying as so
so like I guess I I guess I I wouldn't
say I endorse these acts of Terror but I
but I understand where they're coming
from well if it's in in your way you
have the right to right I don't know I
wonder that well if it's in the middle
of the road you can just say I didn't
see it hit it a little bit F if you hit
it with your car yeah if it's in the row
but if you're on the sidewalk and you
knock it over I've apologized to some
before just like I don't know in my
brain there's someone driving that thing
is there someone driving that thing no
they're automated oh I I've like gotten
in its way and been like oh I'm so sorry
cuz I'll stop it in its tracks and it's
a sentient being to me I want to get a
baseball bat like Negan from The Walking
Dead you know I think I would cry I
watched you take one out just like just
go town on that idiot so
here is the fate of the they Nam these
ones this one's Austin no seem better
days I can't get over also that they
send people's lunches and
and anyone just grabs
it gety up let's go no
Austin maybe get off this
wait this is the same video oh it is
yeah oh then they might be there there's
a different shot in the other video why
don't you find find one of the ones
where he's actually yelling at him yeah
um let's see where he's he's
participating Austin oh so he's actually
has a whole Saga with Austin who's
coming right at me why are you
coming right at me that's aggression
right there
true would be the one to come right at
me that's why that's exactly why you got
atin assaults people he said remember
how you got your ass who
Austin oh man look
it don't pick it up leave him somebody
knock him over who is it idiot it's
Austin Austin who did this my boy why
they do you like
that they steal your food too Austin got
robbed so sad Austin got robbed let's
let's flip out
his mouth is a gate so he so he actually
in some cases is also a robot
savior man nobody else was going to flip
him
over what happened to you
Austin he's back better say thank you
this is the second time I've saved you
Austin the second
[Music]
time what is this
huh what the
what
the history wait you trying to say
Austin was harassing you who knocked
Austin over who assaulted Austin I knock
it over cuz it's evil you you assaulted
Austin no I didn't assault Austin don't
put that on video evil evil in Jesus
name love you boxer Austin didn't tell
you that he attacked that man right
Austin you attacked that man he said you
attacked his legs get my leg get my leg
now on video I got shot
the and and then I died in the
back of the ambulance he almost died he
and I I woke up in the
hospital Austin put him in the hospital
I believe this are dangerous holy
and that's why you got assaulted
and flipped
over where you attacked his legs Austin
and now he's trying to cut you off
Austin I I don't I don't know because
there's certainly no food left in it uh
is finishing the delivery who's paying
for this like there's just no way
that this is anywhere close to
profitable for
anyone like I'm sure these robots cost a
pretty penny and they just get
brutalized out there on the streets man
I feel like Italy is not a good place to
try these out I guess it's like they say
trial by fire I suppose yeah you know
they um my buddy uh when he was going to
college they were all over his campus
really
yeah it was I mean in the courtyard they
were always like roaming H it's so
interesting the robots are
coming that's why you got your ass
whooped right Gizmo he attacked that
Man's legs and he whooped your ass he
Molly wed him Austin got his ass hooked
flipped over and
looted ain't that right Austin so he has
two passions I guess he's both a robot
harasser savior in some cases a
Scientology savior he's also someone
saved me this one of these people that
audits the police is that a separate Tik
Tok uh I don't know about on Tik Tok but
um he has a Twitter account I know an X
account I'm sorry um called film the
police LA I kind of love I know he does
a lot of uh police accountability
activism in La let me see do you have a
link to one uh I do have a link to his
Twitter um he's in the lobby by the way
uh let me just so for those of you who
don't know what he does with
Scientology here's a recent example of
him you know heckling
[Music]
them look at all the seaorg weirdos look
at these weird people you guys are in a
Cult Don't Look Away you guys are in
such a cult where's Danny Merson at this
morning huh
[Music]
huh this is what you guys signed up for
with your billion year contract you guys
signed a billion year contract what I
like about him is that he outra Aton H
so Scientology they have these
um these specialized units that like
counter harassers that will harass any
detractors and uh what I like about him
is that he out crazies them as you're
about to see see how they cross the
street just to go around me
look at this guy comes out of nowhere he
got off the
bus look at him tell me this is an ult
how where's Danny Mar and where's Shelly
has anyone seen Shelly not a single
person has seen
Shelly not a single person mind your
business mind your business what is your
problem you know what my problem is
Scientologist and where Shel at where's
Shell what was that where's Shell this
guy can't do anything he's used to be
able to bully anyone but like he got
nothing off it his name is William
shell I don't know what you're talking
about look at the seor weirdos look at
the get out of my way don't don't you
get my face don't you get my face you
touch me I have a right to defend myself
and I sure as will look at all the
SE weirdos look at them all right look
at
them touch me again don't touch me again
don't touch me again why are you going
to P me
scar
should I wonder if he's a big dude I I'm
curious big muscular T me that's another
time I told you don't touch me who's
look inside of here so so anyway this is
um this is William who I've been
captivated by he's on the call right now
there he
is
William streets
La the
auditor the a what how would you
describe what you do William and by the
way thank you for joining us
thank you for having me um as far as the
Scientology stuff I mean quite honestly
this is a side project I do other stuff
besides this primarily I'm a cop Watcher
that's how I started fighting with these
guys ah was because I was actually
filming a police incident right in front
of the building uh where they had that
bus
pickup um it was like 11 o'clock at
night on a Saturday night that's a side
entrance of an office building how busy
is it right they just didn't want me
there filming the cops so they came and
they just ran interference they were
speaking over the intercoms telling me I
needed to leave from the sidewalk like
they own the sidewalk right and then
they started coming out of the building
trying to bump into me doing it over and
over again finally a security guard came
over got in an argument with me and told
me to suck his you know what he told you
suck his dick no no he said worse he
said suck his which is just a
Scientologist that's so
crude yeah yeah so when he said that I
said okay so now I got to kill your
religion so that was the biggest mistake
they ever made man you know they they
should be regretting that day forever
they should it's even that was an
unforced error I've heard that it's even
uh in terms of tragedies befallen
Scientology it's held even worse than
the day elron hubard died
uh as some the darkest days so um so you
started doing auditing the police what
what inspired that no so I'm a
copwatcher first and foremost um started
uh doing copat watching way back and I
guess like 2020 right after George Floyd
incident I was out there protesting and
I was like you know what just walking
around banging pots and pans and stuff
is not really gonna get anything done
let me go out here and start doing
something for real and I started looking
at police incidents and I
noticed I'll be honest with you it was
just worse than I ever thought it would
be um not as far as violence but as far
as discrepancy with police stops and
stuff like that so I started filming the
police and from there it sort of went on
to other accountability work I consider
myself like an accountability activist I
like going after the mayor the city
council and whoever and quite honest I
getting all these little side beefs here
and there these little projects but yeah
killing Scientology is like number three
on my list oh what's the what and then
the robot and the police is one and too
I'm assuming well listen no listen robot
stuff that's important work
okay no I oh so that's number one you're
saying no that's like number seven
number seven so wait what's one and
two number one is uh getting some real
accountability with LAPD right right
they get half half of our discretionary
budget and they have no accountability
whatsoever um number two is holding the
mayor and city council accountable
especially when it comes to their sort
of homelessness in this
to me that's a huge grift going on
people don't know about Karen bass has
this inside safe operation where they're
putting 1500 homeless people into hotels
45,000 on the street putting 1,500 in
hotels we're paying $177,000 a month per
person 177,000 huh is that right no it's
correct but
who's so 177,000 per person so who's
who's the recipient of all that money so
the hotels and
some of these hotels that they're using
are actually rent controlled apartment
buildings that are illegally converted
to hotels and we're renting those for
between 3,000 and 4,000 a month per room
and then the other 70% of the 177,000
are going to third parties nonprofits
and the homeless industrial complex and
at the same time nothing gets done as
far as homelessness 45,000 people are on
the street right so so it seems like
there would be some level of corruption
going on there where someone who's who's
you know advocating for these gross
wastes of money would also be making
money from it right is that the is that
the theory or is it just bad bad
governance no there's so much corruption
going on cronies are being paid off um
it's just to me I see it as nothing but
scam after scam after scam I listen I'm
G give you a quick example familiar with
the movie pretty woman right you know
that final scene where she's hanging off
the balcony she comes downstairs that's
a rent controlled apartment building
those apartments should be renting for
1,400 a month they legally converted
that building to a hotel and they're
renting it to the city for
4,500 per month per room per room it's
completely illegal and it makes no sense
it's taking rent controlled units off
the market and putting temporary units
on the market and the city is paying and
it's it's a temporary measure 6 months
of of hotel room to homeless people and
then that's it there's no plan after
that one big grip was that a coid thing
or how long no this is this is Karen
bass put this in place when she came
into office she keeps on toting her
emergency measures she's using these
emergency measures to bypass city
council and whoever just last week so I
you know listen I documented the fact
that she had these hotels that she were
she was using po program that were
completely illegal and I CPR afid to get
the documents they finally released them
and I can you know you can prove this I
can prove this now when they released
them and so what they did is they when
she passed an order or she put together
an order where she now
legalized commercial apartment buildings
they'll now be allowed to convert to
hotels so they can then rent those units
to the city for temporary measure rank
control departments are going to come
off of the market and they're going to
be converted into hotels which the city
will now rent to put homeless people in
makes no sense it's real nasty I mean
the idea of converting like empty
commercial buildings into affordable
housing for homeless people it sounds
like it would be a good idea but it
sounds like they're implementing it in
the most up way possible in the
most up way this is a to me this
is a huge betrayal this is the worst
housing policy in decades and she's
enrich ing the people around her using
homelessness and the way she's doing it
it's not addressing anything 1,600 hotel
rooms for six months when there are
45,000 people on the street makes no
sense $117,000 per month per person
makes no sense you can get just give
them 5,000 and say here go get a hotel
they'll figure it out 17,000 per month
so how do you um how do you hold her
accountable do you what's your routine
in terms of documenting
them as far as holding her accountable I
mean you at the end of the day I looked
through I went to the city clerk's
website and I just typed in inside safe
in the search for of contracts and I
started finding all these up
contracts her friends are getting paid
all types of money for doing nothing for
doing fluff work and so these documents
are public I find them I my general
gripe is where is the Press how come the
Press doesn't cover it's inerting to me
I think the press out here in La
sucks almost all of them 95% of them
have you considered compiling them into
your kind of own investigation that you
can put out because I would be
fascinated to read that listen I do
these investigations if people who have
followed me on Twitter and stuff seen
I'm always doing this sort of
investigative work long-term my you know
listen my my primary
my primary project is LAPD right so my
whole goal is listen I'm going to start
my own I think the I think the press out
here sucks yeah so I'm gonna show them
how to do it I'm G to start my own
little Press Company I'm G to focus
solely on lap at first and then Branch
off from there and show people how it's
done yeah you know I I I really
appreciate the
work that uh people do recording the
police because what you see time and
time again is like not only the police
not stand the rights and the laws they
don't care at all like they they they
walk around with ultimate Authority and
impunity and they just don't give a
about what they are and aren't supposed
to do and uh even when people are
recording them they're being flagrant uh
in their violations of our American
rights and watching those video really I
mean listen I'm not a fan of the police
but watching those videos is even more
kind of disturbing seeing how rampant it
is
yeah yeah let me tell you something when
I first started cop watching I was cop
watching mostly in the Hollywood area
specifically the Hollywood H unit they
had about 70 cops back then I'd go to
Hollywood Boulevard and I'd look left
and right and I'd see four stops
happening simultaneously four of them
and so I would just go and I you know go
over and see what the stops were for
95% of the stops were against black and
Latinos um every single stop they were
handcuffed and searched car search every
single stop really failing to oh yeah
listen not using a turn signal search uh
California roll search and like I said
it was 90 95% of the people out there
were black and Latino and keep in mind
black people only make up 5% of
Hollywood not that Hollywood Boulevard
doesn't have a larger percentage just
because the clubs are there and people
come here at the party or whatnot but
this was just
happening solely to them right and it
was disturbing and I was docum meting
this and I filed hundreds of complaints
over this this hundreds and hundreds
thousands over incidents like that and
over the course of time I found
documentation that I was able to put so
much pressure they decreased the number
of HED cops from 70 down to 23 wow in
like a year and a half that's signicant
at the same time Prime did not go up
Prime decreased right so I'm not saying
that less cost means less crime what I'm
saying is the the coral The Narrative
that that the only way to decrease
crime or if you have less cops it will
lead to increased crime which is not
true
MH yeah that's a TR that that was a big
issue with the defund the police
movement which was essentially you
know lower than budet uh what they get
50% of our they get 50% 50% of our
discretionary budget 50% and as crime
has reached listen there's a narrative
going around here that crime is out of
control if you look the crime it's at
2018 2019 levels which were the safest
times in three decades all right so
we're at near decades low what we have
now is we have citizen app and we have
social media and Tik Tok where you're
seeing videos of stuff that you weren't
seeing five 10 years ago but crime is
down significantly but yet we just
increased the police budget by almost $
hundred million added 750 more cops
which we're giving them $115,000 signing
bonuses the average cop makes
$132,000 a year after overtime 100 with
the over time got it yeah with the
overtime I'm going to tell you I've
looked up hundreds of cops total pay
that's a lot of money I've only seen I
mean listen it's we have other needs we
have other needs out here we don't need
three cops sitting at a front desk doing
nothing watching whatever Newsmax we
don't need that there's other things we
could do with that money I look around
at Hollywood's a mess pay some people
that walk around and clean up have you
um been arrested or retaliated against
by the cops for
anyone ah so I've been arrested now I've
been arrested or they've attempted to
prosecute me five times um one time this
inent was crazy I I saw a guy he he was
having a mental health issue and he was
throwing bottles and furniture at cars
and I went over and yelled him me to
stop throwing at cars and stuff and he
said I'm homeless and I said I don't
care if you're homeless and he went to
his tent and I went and cleaned the
stuff out of the street he comes back
with a knife and pole and I'm a tough
guy but I'm not going to stick around
for that yeah right and like three four
hours later I hear sirens and stuff I
hop on a scooter I go over to that same
area and somebody called the police on
him because he was walking up down the
street threatening people with a knife
and his pole they had him in handcuffs
and as soon as I got there the guy said
hey that guy over there he threatened to
burn down my tent earlier they took
handcuffs off of him and put him on to
me what they let him go yeah they let
him go and arrested me for criminal
threats and you know $50,000 bail seized
two got search warrants for two of my
phones Michael Moore the next day
admitted that the guy was having a
mental health crisis but yeah he was
like oh I got arrested that was one time
another time they tried to prosecute me
for EAS dropping because I recorded my
conversation with an officer uh who's
given me an official explanation on
behalf of Michael Moore over the phone
so I recorded it it was over a a cop
taking a woman to a secluded area and
who knows what the hell he was planning
on doing before I caught him and so
since I recorded that and since I
confronted Michael Moore with it they
tried to arrest me for eavesdropping
even though I was perfectly legal to
record that conversation no expectation
of privacy for an officer handling an
official call while in an office this is
not Michael Moore is the chief of the
LAPD you by the way if people don't know
corre
so you have a good lawyer how do you
have you ever been like totally
or usually getting finding your way out
listen they do this all the time to
me they keep on trying to prosecute me
for little things I have stepped into
court one time and they called my name
they said William good and it's as I
stood up they said dismissed and that
was it that was the only time that I've
actually made it the court it's all Bo
they do a thing called called trying to
take you for the ride right they just do
this little so they can seize my
phones for months and who knows they can
search them back right and then you know
expect you to go through all this you
know the process but no this is it's all
gone nowhere I perfect listen when they
try to do that I enjoy it I don't
give a with I like it right it
doesn't bother me at all it makes them
look stupid yeah that is a thing I've
noticed too watching these police
auditing uh videos is
that they know what they're doing like
they know it's a arrest I've
seen like a body Cam that people got
from like a what do you call that the
freedom of uh
information fo and they're they're they
they have this guy who did nothing wrong
they want to arrest him it's not a
serious charge they just want to ruin
his day right so they're going
there and they're like what do we charge
him for you know uh should we do like a
you know public nuisance what do you
think would and so they're they are bad
faith a lot of them are just total bad
faith it's crazy man
what how do yeah and you can't get
access to the body cam so they can talk
that and there's nothing you can do
about it you can't foil listen no zero
no you have to have you can only get it
through a subpoena that's the only way
so it must be it doesn't matter it's
it's listen unless you have an actual
lawsuit and it reaches that stage right
and quite honestly if there's some
incriminating they just
settle beforehand right but you can't
get access unless there's an actual use
of force shooting and stuff that has to
be released within 40 day 45 days other
than that you're not getting access to
body cam footage is not not the LAPD at
least sounds like a good organization we
got there who has yeah has no oversite
whatsoever right
um so one one question I was curious
because I know scientologists are pretty
notorious for harassing their detractors
H have they tried to with you it
anyway so I mean listen this is a unique
situation so the scientologists have a a
really good relationship with the LAPD
and I'm sure that once I started doing
what I'm doing they went to the lap
especially the senior Leal officers in
Hollywood and we're like you know we got
this guy and he's just with us
and he won't leave us alone you know
what can you do to help us and they
probably said listen you know we have a
long history with William we're not
going to get involved you know they're
not going to come save him just shut
your mouth and he'll go
something H sorry and and they thought
that I you know they're now learning to
shut their mouth but at one time
they tried to yeah they tried to do some
harassment I got to my corner and they
had a black Prius with its lights off
sitting at the corner you know so it was
it didn't I didn't know it was there I
didn't know somebody was there and as
I'm going through this you know the
intersection they just sped right in
front of me like I had this guy back
from just terrorizing the out of
him and so they sped through and came
close to hitting me and I thought it was
funny and then I was like an insult you
going to use a Prius you
couldn't get a
damn the scariest right I mean like come
on and other than that no that honestly
like I said they're notorious for having
being known for like terrorizing people
yeah but are they really doing that they
get I think they get a lot of mileage
off of the perception right and so I'm
just calling them out and that's my
primary function with this is call him
out show them they're not they're not
scary these guys are not scary there's
they're just goofy and they're what can
they do to you what are they one thing
that I appreciate that you continue to
point out that I think is probably one
of the best points to go after the
religion are those tight vests man uh
they you really really nailed it on that
one can you guys pull you got to see the
tight vests I mean it's unbelievable
what is that I don't know I just looks
ridiculous they should update that
because they stand out they like I said
they look like B HS failed Disney actors
um and from the back it looks like you
could like literally see their lungs I
don't know I don't know their shoes are
oversized all of them they just clunk
around I don't know it's it's honestly
so I used to really mock them hard when
I first started doing really mocking
them hard I actually starting to feel
bad about it because some of their
family members have been reaching out to
me oh really saying wow yeah and saying
that they sing family members on there
that I haven't seen in seven years oh
man that is that is horrible
that's sad I mean well they said things
like you know I asked them you want me
to give them a message and they're like
I don't want to freak anybody out where
they'll move him someplace else and I
won't see him again for years that's a
sad situation you know to me that's I
used to have no sympathy for any of them
I was like you know you're part of this
I gotta take out this religion and you
know you chose to join up for it you're
gonna be held accountable but I you know
some of them I feel bad for and not
angel angel p I do not feel bad
for that's the uh is that the guard or
the guy who was in your face yeah yeah
oh that's no no the guy in my face
that's Frank so Frank he used to be a
model for he was their poster child a
decade or so ago maybe two decades ago
he was on tons of posters and he now
he's just old and worn out broken down
and where does he go so he's a security
guard now he thought he was going to be
going somewhere with this and he's out
there just thinking he's to scare
somebody just by getting in my face I I
I look for him I keep I want to see him
again because he's so goofy and I like
him front him here here I pulled up a
video so I can show you guys the the
vests hold on let me oh yeah dude these
vests are nuts the black C look at
them look at him look at this guy will
take out his corset tightest you
the is that it's the tightest vest
I've ever seen
Jesus you see his lungs look at it you
can see individual lung it's really form
fitting you you know you better be fit
if you're going to squeeze into one of
those my fat ass ain't
a you know they know what they're doing
though because you see how they have
them set up right they put out generally
goodlooking true but the other ones that
they're generally good-looking and they
speak multiple languages some of them
that that guy right there he speaks like
I said I've seen him speak Italian farsy
uh Spanish waste of a talented person
yeah he's getting 50 bucks a week 50
bucks Jesus Christ no I mean but I bet
you he got into this he's got roped into
it 10 15 years ago and here he is still
doing this and this is listen he's got
to pay so many thousands of dollars to
go up levels he's kind of be stuck there
where is he goingon to go where is he
going to do from you know from I don't
know you seem to have his particular
love interest love or let's say yeah
interest uh love hate interest with this
specific spot in Hollywood I'm assuming
everyone there knows who you are are and
do you just cruise up and park outside
like how do how do you stake it out no
no listen that's like five six seven
blocks from my house and I'm so you know
I I'm always walking around or jogging
and sometimes I'm like you know let me
go over there and with them for a
minute stir them up get them all worked
up I just make them feel uncomfortable
even if it's just for five
minutes or you know I'll walk to the
smoothie shop on the way home or just
walk in my dog and just stop by and
with him so no I mean I'm only there for
a few minutes a day um but to me it's
effective enough yeah listen after this
after this happened after they pissed me
off and I said I was going to kill him I
was like well how would I do this what
was my plan I came up with a little plan
I was like I'll do this create a Tik Tok
account and I'll have these encounters
because they're so goofy I'm like if if
I can you know build up a Tik Tok
account yelling at robots and
yelling at these people this is so much
better like people love robots no one
likes to Scientology no true so this is
just I'm Ser I get listen I used to in
my Tik Tok account with the robots I get
messages of people saying hey you know
if you keep on with those robots
I'm going to come find you I'm going run
you out of La stop with Marcus
things like that I don't get that with
the
S who are these people defending the
robots listen I'm gonna tell you that
Tik Tok account they get some some weird
people weird messages some people some
some people are really mad at the robots
individual robots like yo I'm
sick of Marcus I'm going to come up here
I'm G to find him and I'm burn I'm like
I got to pull back
so I I want I wanted to ask you are you
on a serious Crusade against these
Street robots or is this just a goof no
so I mean I got into doing this just I
was just goofing around just doing it it
was you know everybody a lot of people
in Hollywood filming they're everywhere
I can't leave my I cannot walk five
blocks without seeing three or four of
them you're gonna see them all over so I
would just when I see him just film and
talk a little to him I wasn't I
didn't have any real I don't have any
real beef with them listen I think think
that they are replacing a human it's
true yeah it's kind of up um and
so I have you know I feel uncomfortable
with that but other than that I mean
people around here I talk to my
neighbors they seem to like them for
whatever reason I thought they were
creepy looking but it well people
are saying that they did feel bad for
Austin although I want to commend you on
your humanitarian effort there you
really showed your softer side and how
saving and reaching out to Austin in a
meaningful way that was touching no
lost him because when I lifted him up
when I lifted him up he cut my hand I
had a
deep what a scumbag and on on
top of it I saw I was at two police
incidents where people were pulled over
and when I got
there Austin was right there like a
snitch so Austin probably
deserve
it true they are cam they have cameras
and mics you never know man they they've
actually have supplied video in a case
oh and that's crazy one there was a
story came out a few weeks ago about
that where somebody tried to steal one
of them and they supplied the video to
the cops and the rested them so I mean
listen I don't know how I feel about
that I think people I think people have
you have a right to defend your property
and pro protect it from getting stolen I
just wonder about these roaming cameras
on the street that could be
potentially you know be handing over
video to the police
without the cens actually deciding is
that what we want we want we want to be
involved if we're going to put police
cameras on individual Corners we have
these things roaming around freelancing
for the police I think we should have a
say in that right here it is Uber eat
spot shares video with LAPD privacy
concerns
rise look at this who's this do
you recognize him or or you have to see
the name looks like that looks like you
go to me
Hugo that's a snitch people who know me
people who that's a snitch Hugo is a
snitch people who know me know what I'm
talking about you in the eyes um I want
to see one of your police videos I
haven't actually watched here let me let
me take a look at
this you got the sidewalk monitors look
at this guy this guy well he looks like
Mr Personality right
here this is where our money goes the
average cop makes 132,000 a year wait so
what are they doing why is there so many
cops there um it was Halloween I just
wanted to show a presents and they had
like 20 cops out there individual
Corners got it got it got it P3 over
here makes a little bit
more right now they're getting overtime
doing sidewalk monitor
Duty I guess they're protecting a
building that's hasn't been open in the
decades decades doing the sidewalk
monitor
Duty they should be I guess like they
should be doing something right like
they're just standing there I mean what
do we what do we want should they be
patrolling should they be at home
listen if at tonight I'll go if I were
to go over behind the city council
office which connects to the Hollywood
building Hollywood Police Station I go
to that parking lot at one o'clock in
the morning I'm gonna see five or six
cop cars with cops looking at Tik Tock
looking at streets La Tik Tok stuff like
that and it's
while while they're sitting
around doing absolutely nothing the
majority of a cop's time is sitting
around doing nothing and they say there
we need more cops we need more cops we
have an abundance of cops let tell you
they're just they're plenty of amount
there but this is where I do get budget
I do get that impression because cops
are they kind of do a lot of
self-management with their time it seems
like and a lot of cops are
just again I'm speaking broadly but they
just seem like lame people and so I can
totally see them just pulling over
watching Tik Tok eating a hamburger and
oh no I mean it's it's in Hollywood it's
become strategic so I used to find them
in the behind the police station so they
stopped hiding there they went and hid
over in this new apartment complex that
opened since it's private property but I
didn't care I just roll a scooter up in
there showing what they're doing at 2
o'clock in the morning one o'clock in
the morning and then I they started
hiding on Sunset in the commercial
parking lot and I'll roll roll through
there they spend their shifts looking
for ways to do nothing that's really
what they do well I don't know they say
it's a really dangerous job and that's
why they deserve to get paid so much
money
yeah but as far as rankings of the most
dangerous drops they don't rank in the
top 10 they don't rank in the top 20
right I mean food food delivery drivers
have a higher death rate you know
construction workers uh Steel Workers
why aren't they yeah I mean so what are
we doing here why are they getting all
this yeah they get all the Goodwill I
think I think Garder might have been
number one no I think we were like
shocked by it I'm I'm going to look it
up and uh we we just looked into this
this actually yeah recently so here let
me watch this video voted for that you
voted to add another th000
cops give $155,000 signing bonuses this
is where your money goes half of our
discretionary budget and on top of it
94% of them don't even live in the city
of La 94%
don't really I've seen cops 94% don't
live in
LA
94% of LAPD officers do not live in the
city of Los Ang what where do they live
SEI San ber San Bernardino yes
SEI County oh listen we have we have 30s
something cops that live out of state
that live out of state what yeah we have
cops that live in Vegas we have cops
that live in Idaho we have cops that
live in Tennessee listen I actually
confronted a cop last uh last LAPD
Christmas party he lives in Tennessee
and you know I I I found his social
media researched him up he sold his
house here in Thousand Oaks moved to
Tennessee got season tickets for the
Tennessee Titans and it's doable it's so
you can set up your schedule so you only
have to work three hour three day work
weeks yeah yeah three 12 three three 12
hour shifts and you get four days off
and you reverse it the following week
and you have four days off and three
days on so it basically Works Six Days
on eight days off so that justifies them
driving so far but what you said sounds
so outlandish but here it is at least
two dozen LAPD officers live outside of
the state yet La tax SPS pay their
salaries what the what's the
explanation for
that
um a lot of ways they save money quite
honestly so I mean you can get if you
live in Boise Idaho you can get a plane
ticket from here to there you know
you're really Tak you're taking one
plane a week wait they fly people from
Idaho into LA because it's
cheaper well I mean they say or because
they want
toing it's cheap I'll tell you my
girlfriend friends from there and so I
know it so the savings of living there
is probably offsets flying back and
forth for your job it does make sense
but it's so Outland yeah well how much
does it cost for a plane ticket like 80
bucks from here to maybe aund 50 at most
it's probably like 100 bucks 150 on the
shuttle and so you're you're taking it
once a week one you know every weekend
back in fourth one plane a week holy
they share Apartments they have
multiple cops will share Apartments here
uh close to the station and they'll use
that and they actually save money
because you can buy a huge Manion for
like 100,000 bucks in Idol as opposed to
here right I think I've heard I think
it's known that police generally are far
very conservative I mean the police
Union and the police are pretty magged
out and so I don't think they like La
Los Angeles I don't think they like the
they hate us well that's that's
important that's an important point that
you brought up so every time I have
ideal Poli I always I always look at
cops where they live and what I do that
because I want to see what policing is
like between cops that are that live in
LA versus outside cops that live in LA
honestly they please differently right
they you know they care a little bit
more somebody who lives in Tennessee or
Idaho or in Las Vegas they're like
them or Long Beach you know yeah
yeah they don't give a they don't
care and they look down on everybody
they on the city they talk honestly
if you listen to a cop on during the
course of the shift they spend their
time grumbling about how much they
hate the hole as they're
literally milking us for everything
we've got they can retire at 50 they're
taking care for the rest of their life
because of the way the laws are written
they can because of their belts the belt
the utility belts they wear they can
retire in like 10 years if they claim
they have a back problem they can even
actually get just by claiming
anything any back problem ever is
automatically attributed to the belts so
it's just I can go on forever with I'm
I'm really surprised by that stat that
most so many of them are living out of
the city I feel like it would make sense
to just they have to live in the city if
you're going to police the city you got
to live there well they they listen so
or LA County at least well they
said they're trying to address that so
it's not that they're mandating it but
they are now offering incentives new
cops if you live in the city of La
they'll they're paying a rent they're
paying part of their rent they're paying
a subsidy up to 20 up to uh
$24,000 $1,000 a month for up to two
years to help get you know get them rent
you know and listen I feel a certain way
about that because again you're starting
off your first year you're GNA make over
$100,000 after overtime you're already
making what what profession do you know
where and I'm not knocking geds but what
profession do you know where with a GED
you start off and you can make $100,000
a year I can't think of it the LA PD is
about the only one you can think of and
again I'm not knocking geds I'm just
saying though you know they they're
they're very well taken care of they
have all sorts of perks and then we're
going to add another rent subsidy to
help them out where why don't you do
that for the bus drivers and the cooks
and whoever else nobody you know they're
not getting that they don't need anymore
they got plenty true well I gotta say
William uh I'm I got to say you you know
your stuff man uh you you I learned some
stuff from you today and
I endorse what you're doing and I
appreciate it and I think you're a real
interesting cool dude I appreciate it
man I want I want people to go follow
you you're on uh Tik Tok your La what
was one well your main uh yeah plug plug
your spots yeah where do you want people
to go yeah so I mean the main account
that I use is my Twitter account film
the police
LA um and then I'm filming the police LA
on
YouTube I'm film the police LA on
Instagram uh I had you know they they
took down my Tik toks I'm my film the
police Tik toks I'm pissed off that I
feel like rebuilding it um that sucks
then with my Tik Tok with the
Scientology stuff it's uh streets La my
my backup for that is Scientology audit
and then my YouTube for that is
Scientology audit so I'll put all the
links in the description so people know
where to find you but I really
appreciate you calling
in thank you having me I'll keep we're
going to follow along as you uh continue
to hold him accountable but thank you
yeah and scient science I told him in a
year I'm gonna end them I'm tell done I
look forward to that all right thank you
William nice job thank
Youk
um what a what a character what an
interesting guy yeah you know he really
does seem to know his stuff with the
police and the LA stuff I it was when I
put together that he was the film The
Police La guy um it kind of shocked me
because i' I've I've keeped tabs on him
for a while now for a couple years and
so I was aware of that account didn't
know it was the same person as the
Scientologist the robot guy and the
robot guy right yeah it it's all
connected man it's the
Trinity um here I wanted to finish this
video some that live in
Idaho Tennessee New
Jersey I think there's over 30 that live
out of state making 132,000 like I said
a sergeant makes a little bit more he
makes okay whatever yeah I mean
listen that shocked the hell out of me
80% live outside of La wow that's soar
yeah I found I I don't know if we got a
chance to show it on screen but I found
an LA time article that was
corroborating that and uh yeah only 20%
or 21% I think it said live in LA I mean
it's interesting cuz it's like if that's
a problem the stip end that they're
offering to try and incentivize them
living in La makes sense but he said
it's only for new officers which it's
like I mean you know I guess that's a
matter of opinion but I agree with him
we got plenty of cops here in La like
half the budget right half the budget
yeah and La is a rich city I mean we La
collects a lot of taxes city taxes sure
most cities do not do that um it is a
wealth we there's a lot of income here
in La for the city uh kir said I work 3
16-hour days every week as a dialysis
clinic and I don't get half of the pay
benefits the cops do yeah well your
work's not as
important hate to break it to
you who cares about the they don't have
a working kidney it's their fault
right
um yeah but that's that's another thing
I haven't thought about is that if you
go down to Long Beach it's like total
magga country down there it's like a
whole conservative enclave and so well
or maybe not Long Beach but Orange
County justy yeah once you hit Orange
County it's definitely a different vibe
if these are the people coming up and
policing La mhm well and in SEI too SEI
is like magga country as well and a lot
of them live Valley right
yeah how
weird yeah he seems tall too by the way
which just explains why
the we should have asked him
H my throat is killing me you guys uhoh
I'm starting to talk even softer and
softer throat L maybe that' be a good
idea chocolate is the worst idea no
chocolate is super acidic and it makes
heartburn
worse but it's yummy yeah isn't a dark
chocolate uh give you gird you know my
gird has been pretty good cuz I I'm
medicated i u my medicine recently
too so my G my gird is at least it
doesn't outwardly hurt me
but I think it still up my throat
cuz I constantly do have a cough would
you like some
pepid that doesn't help me I don't think
my stomach's the problem I'm just
up dude why did you say it like that
what' I say no not you Sam I said would
you like some
pepid did I say it weird the first time
I thought you said it kind of weird I
didn't think cheeky in a very cheeky by
the way here's uh Here's the final boss
here Dark Souls music starts playing for
William dude that's Murphy man it's a
cop scient it's a cop Scientologist
robot that's Murphy dude uh people are
saying Huntington Beach is where the
magga people live yes Huntington Beach
Newport as well newport's where we
filmed the thing with idubbz and we saw
dude we went down there voting for a
video and all these have
Maga Flags it's crazy and it's like what
an hour south dud boter love Donald
Trump the people with boats specifically
what's the connection he loves the I
think boats just kind of represent a
certain like people that own boats tend
to be from a certain subset of social
class that heavily leans um conservative
and like keep going tell me more
annoying people I mean this is just me
speculating but like it's definitely a
pattern you saw it yourself like boat
people love Trump remember uh in
the last election there was the boat uh
the boat parade right having boat
parades all the time the boat people
love Trump we love the boat people the
boat the boats are fine people we love
the fine people on the sea we love them
we love wow lap
R LAPD sucks man good for him appreciate
that
um let's see you guys want to order food
now we've been
waiting we've been waiting all our lives
now listen everybody watching
mhm we in an effort to make the show run
better decided let's decide on food
before we start yeah but this was met
with preferably even eat before we start
that's not be my ideal world yeah you
want to live in Utopia I get it
mhm where we where we eat before we do
the I my dream man the world if we ate
before the podcast that beautiful meme
yeah um but there was a lot of push back
I love when the crew orders food on the
show please please please do not and end
ordering food segments on the show with
peace and love I love the debate the
drama the anticipation The Taste the
near doxing when Ethan opens the
Restaurant's menu the anger read the
delivery
time right okay so this is a passion
it's got 2,000 points so it's serious
let's do a poll though there's 2,000 I
mean there's like 40,000 people watching
right now well let's do a poll okay
let's see should we order food before
the show or during the show MH order
food before and as you said that up Sam
you got any
ideas H what
about I don't know Mexican I like
Mexican always Mexican I like Mexican I
can have Mexican food every day same gen
let's do Mexican let me see what type of
options we're working with I actually
ate five tacos right before the show
five yeah Taco Bells no what was it like
something G Taco G uh like a real Tak
Taco maybe I don't it was nice play it's
like kind of the real life version of uh
poos foros from breaking bad
they're a chain I wish I think it's a
small chain like a la chain I check my
door door Dash hold on was yummy though
so the people this is really interesting
I I don't think any of us expected it
but here it is should we order food
before or after the show during during
has it 72% during that's crazy that is
well during the show they love the food
crazy I get it all right I personally I
don't think it's bad if I thought it
wasn't entertaining I wouldn't
willing to admit I'm wrong the audience
likes it what can I say to me it's like
I I think it would get a little old
hearing us order food all the time I do
fear that yeah I do fear that but it was
always my favorite it was always
surprising it's it's never the same just
like I mean it's real it's raw the drama
ra it's as real as it gets do you have a
good Mexican place in mind Sam um I was
thinking the place that we got last time
the breakfast bre burito spot that El
always gets
from maybe there's one that I got a
breit from that was pretty good the one
Elina the one that El always gets a
burrito from I'm sending it in the group
right now in the chat but I'm I'm open
to try a new spot too
Sam send me your spot and I'll peep that
menu I'll send
options we just got a $500 donation
Jesus Christ saying please stop ordering
on the show no you got two pretty please
there's two
500 it might have just glitched and
shown twice Jesus Christ man
well is here's my here's my response
thanks for the lunch
money damn oh you can't buy an election
oh my love holy though thank you
for that donation that's crazy I what
can I tell you though I mean listen I'm
a man of the people they the people have
spoken uh they love it well are are you
a popular or do you believe that money
rules politics because we're there's
$500 in the pool for I'm a populist four
and
zero I'm a pop I'm not I'm not so you're
not okay he can't be bought people we
just got lobed pretty hard he can't
can't get bought lob sorry relle but
thank I'm clicking the menu Ian warning
oh I'm telling you all right it it
opened right oh so this is the burrito
spot that I like yeah and then what's
the other one Samantha I'm getting the
link for right now on
you call her Sam Ian or do you ever pop
out Samantha do that ever happen I use
the full government when things are
getting serious really when you guys
have disagreements
Samantha no not really hate being called
by my full
name does your mom call you Samantha or
just Sam no one calls me my full name
not one person I thought about like
legally changing my name to just Sam to
just Sam really that's I mean nobody
calls me Daniel like ever
I call you Daniel's son sometimes yeah I
guess like MiMi like that but I'm just
Dan Daniel just like that doesn't even
sound like my name that's weird that's
I'll be honest I won't I won't reveal I
will never reveal the secret language
but I don't think I call Sam Sam ever
you guys have pet names for each other
madeup words I I I I know
exactly what you
mean yeah you too I know what you me and
Ela used to do that less so now because
the kids and it's confus using but there
was probably a stretch of five or six or
seven years where we never used each
other's name huh where it's just you
know pet names and stuff right how it is
with me and Shanti please tell me your
pet names for each other
please I have to know no it's the secret
language no no no Sam would you be
willing to divulge no Zach what about
you no it's between me and her G cuz
it's so embarrassing isn't it so
embarrassing well it's not embarrassing
I person person Al I guess it would be
the better way to I find it super
embarrassing would you want to reveal
what never you never your pet name fora
no wow it's just it's very do you have
one ab and Lena you guys doing the pet
name thing uh no I mean I call her Lenny
and no one really calls her Lenny and
also that's not a pet name no yeah Snips
snip Snips is one we knew about the
Snips one because she broke your
dick she been calling me that way before
way before wait why why snip way I think
when we work together at a restaurant
like she can never be mean to anyone she
just sometimes we get a little snippy
oh little snippy huh sppy yeah I haven't
seen that side of her yeah I don't know
but also people always ask if Lena is is
short for something and I'm like no
that's my name what could it be short
for I don't know right I get that a lot
actually Selena that's a different name
well I guess like what else could it be
short for
Lina Lina Lina maybe because I'm Arab
and Arab names are usually more
complicated is my guess why people would
ask that yeah um by the way let's do I
don't know how you guys feel but let's
do the one spot that Ela gets the
breakfast burritos from because I've had
that place Sam and I think
it's mid you not you had the second one
that I said yeah yeah yeah okay okay
it's one of these SP this is I have a
general rule with Mexican food mhm
there's no such thing as fancy or even
mid-range Mexican
food if they're trying to sell you
Mexican
food at a markup because it's the food
it's just that's not it's not good the
they try too hard you know can I give
you a counter argument on that go ahead
there's this place in Santa Barbara that
is a specific type of Mexican food it's
a a w talking MH Mexican food and it is
a little more upscale it's a little more
expensive however I do find it is
worth the premium the premium on it yeah
you want to give the name I forgot the
name of it um what is w
hawen it Waka is in Mexico it's a state
Mexico right yeah oh so okay okay but
hands down the most amazing Mexican food
I've ever had in my life really yeah
well give me the name don't hold
out um
give him a shout out like that who's
that guy on Tik Tok that's like the the
restaurant
guy
Keith let's be like Keith let's let's
make their whole life right now Zach all
right I'm trying to find the name of it
not to be uh over the top but I think we
can save their life right now Los agavez
is the name Los
agavez I believe that is the name yes
okay and Santa Barbara yeah
yes lot of agreement with you I see one
in off Zach in the
chat I see one in Oxnard is it a chain I
don't think so let me see in Santa
Barbara loave is Mexican Santa
barbar is this it did you recognize this
dining uh
room yes that is it ooh traditional
authentic handmade yeah that sounds good
that's what the that's what Mexican food
is all about in my opinion it's like
just okay so distinction here cuz that's
uh they have multiple locations wait is
this the one yes the the S Barbara Ox
where's
goita uh I know that
name SoCal so it's all in Ventura it
sounds like Ventura County Lita is oh
it's right it's right next to Santa
Barbara it's in that same area guys LA's
right here what come on wait now I'm now
I'm thinking this is not it
what I have to see the the hold on hold
on oh Zach I've had wait hold on nobody
order from there yeah take it back
I have to find it uh my throat is
killing me that's the outside I was
thinking of doing leftovers tomorrow but
my body might be telling me
no that's what I just got over my throat
was killing me sucks
[Music]
worst
all right let me pick something out
here you like wet burritos love or is
that a weird thing for you well you
introduced me to that first time when I
was here last year and that's the last
time I had it uh it's a lot it's a lot
which sauce did you get red or green
green the red one is where it's at
really no no no the enchilada sauce you
would like that trust me they don't if I
was hungry right now I'd take it but
next time I will I can't enjoy green
sauce anymore I just think of the pesto
put that in my
head nothing could turn me off salsa day
yeah true that's not fair that's not
fair it's a different consisten can't
control it I see it every time I look at
it I see him everywhere I go it's not
fair I'm just going to get some horada
or whatever it's called
yeah I do I like that you've come to LA
and
immediately just dived right into all
the Mexican Cuisine cuz that's uhhuh
that's you can talk a lot of about
La we got good ass food here yeah and
that's something that's like in Sweden
there's no like there's nothing Mexican
God I love Mexican food there's
just you can't it's the best dude it's
the best and the thing is like all
around the world you see people trying
to do open Mexican restaurants and it's
like yeah they don't know how to do it
they don't have the magic it's just not
it they don't have the Mexicans frankly
frankly you're right exactly I found the
name of the restaurant go ahead de
May that is completely different yes
throat day my East Flor day my floor
like flower yes day my
East spell my East is that corn M oh may
can you spell it for me or no uh f l o r
mhm d d e m a i z m a i oh maze corn
yeah yeah flower of
corn
okay oh oh this looks super fancy
what the it's good there's
like a whole Tomahawk Steak there their
uh their tacos are Next Level bro oh
this is actually yeah this is super
fancy it looks like it looks
delish and it's right on the sorry go
ahead Dan I I was just going to say this
is kind of
putting Ethan's Theory to the test yeah
maybe it's not a hard I mean it's in
Santa Barbara otherwise I'd say you
should maybe try it you know I'm not so
much talking about a place like this cuz
I see they're doing their own thing it's
like when you go to a place and you get
a burrito or you get whatever and it's
30 bucks because they're using organic
beans or some you know
yeah give me give me a $6
burrito any day
right all right so are you guys looking
at the menu this the
spot I love nachos I feel like that's a
personality
defect you know what I mean like you
love nachos and that's a personality
defect the fact that I order nachos for
an entree I feel reflects poorly on yeah
yeah I admire that I love it though yeah
I admire that you do that I would
sometimes I've thought about it it's
embarrassing though right no then why
don't you well you're right that's why I
hav done it it is embarrassing I admire
the tenacity that exists in that I I got
to say Mexican food reheats amazingly
too I'll get i'll get or I do this thing
very often as a bad trade I think I
ordered twice as much food as I need and
I just eat eat the rest next day and it
just reheats amazingly especially tacos
I eat it cold was is fine I don't even
wait as long as you eat as long as
you're not throwing it away no I never
throw away no even if it's just
like one taco lat as as a little
ler nachos is also probably the dirtiest
hardest to eat during a
live that in ribs are terrible date
Foods yeah why get some use some ribs
dude I can't I don't know why hyper
specific dude going on a first date and
ordering nachos is just so funny to
me you want to share nachos yeah that's
funny
man so I guess
do I get nachos or do I get a
breit Chad are you not
entertain really right it's a bad idea
skip the nachos it's good burrito it's
nice it's it's contained you know it's
all wrapped up for you
clean go lot of carbs
though right well the nachos are carbed
up too deep fried carbs actually even
worse hamburger is six bucks here that's
how you know it's good yeah
um they have kind of a extensive
menu did you guys already decide yeah
well I did do other people not everyone
though you guys like mole or no
yeah yeah what is that it's it's it's
not my vibe yeah it's like a it's
like a rich thick sauce but it's made of
chocolate I feel like you would love it
you're a big sauce you might I'll try it
out for sure it is giving it might be
giving kind of the Japanese Curry
flavors right right thick
thick
it's my tits
bro this can't be entertaining there's
no way yeah you make a make a call here
let's pick up the pace a little bit the
people wanted this this is what the
people wanted oh maybe you're right AB
make this as painful
POS okay so I don't see a normal burrito
I see meat burrito I don't want a
burrito of just meat that's oh no does
it they have normal burritos just let me
know which one meat beans rice
onions
okay so let's do the meat burrito with
chicken got it and there's no cheese
inside what can we do something about
that I've noticed some burrito makers
they don't put cheese inside and I can't
I I can't really endorse that oh that's
OD you I can add cheese you want cheese
yes please okay is there an option for
extra
salsa um or maybe a
side there's not actually can you ride
in the field yeah yeah I can nice nice
okay there it is food is ordered my
[Music]
friends
there it is everybody's
order the stars are aligned oh there it
is the order is out what's the estimated
delivery time Sam with the with the
priority um I can't see right now I
think it was 20 minutes so probably 20
minutes dude I will be skipping singing
and dancing and praising their name if
it gets here in 20 minutes so I order
from G gavan gavon gavon Tacos El gavon
and they came here in 15 minutes really
weird wow I love that yeah God
bless
him five minutes I I got to be honest my
throat is really
hurting Dam
uhoh you know the fact that I talk for a
living 4 hours
continuously nearly every
[Music]
day is that could that be a reason why I
get all these throat like my throat I
feel like every month it happens I feel
like it's cuz you have kids yeah I was
about to say this it's your
kids
um all right let's see if I can work
through
this here's a good one about
Jeff this is a super weird
um Rabbit
Hole yeah exactly Jeff talks about a
crazy encounter he had with the girl
that did the eye sculpture for David do
now just to jog your
memory to connect the lines here of
causality ey girl David Dober let's see
if that shows
up she
made eye girl I guess that wasn't good
enough uh sculpture oh wait I saw it
yeah it was at the top row it is here oh
yeah so this girl made this giant
eye sculpture for David which a
lot of people thought was in poor taste
understandably Jeff one of them
being and so which I always just assumed
was just bad timing weird coincidence
like a weird coincidence not like cuz
she's an artist right and just I I think
makes eyeball stuff seems to be fairly
talented as well I me pretty cool
sculpture take it away from the context
yeah it's pretty cool so well so this is
so bizarre now I'll let Jeff tell the
story and then I'll unpack it uh more if
I can but I'll let Jeff tell the
tale story about what happened he was
IRL streamer yeah yeah yeah so um I was
out a couple we or like a month ago now
I'm out at the store and this girl she's
like oh you're Jeff Whit oh my God I'm
the girl that made the eye statue for
David and I'm like cool like oh yeah
that's great work she was like oh I know
is that there sounds yeah sounds like
Kyle's stealing uh it's all right I
understand I mean if anyone has a right
to to blast D brick sound bites it's
definitely them I love Kyle too he's a
good dude shout out he looks up to you
Zach yeah he's a really good dude he
idolizes you yeah he really looks up to
you
yeah felt bad like after I saw the
comments like I should have made it for
you or enough of this scoring it's too
much um and as she's doing that that
whole interaction her boyfriend pulls
out the phone and starts filming me and
like trying to troll me he's doing like
an IRL stream and or like filming a
video to post after or some I don't
know what the he was doing but he
had his phone on me so I got to be nice
you know and now he starts going Jeff is
such a character I got to be nice you
know he's like such an Italian tough guy
but we love him he's Italian right yeah
Italian good old boy you know yeah I've
been in prison so what I ain't know
nothing about nobody I don't know why I
thought he was Jewish you did not I did
I thought he might have
there's no way that man's Jewish whiten
I thought was his name Whit Stein yeah
he's a good Italian boy Z shame on you I
mean the Jews and Italians they kind of
run parallel in the
sense so what is it like to have one eye
and like that while his phone is
2 Ines away from my face so I'm
ready to snap now this man okay I'll
blow him but I'm keeping it cool cuz if
you get mad on video you lose you know
that you know you had that video where
you're pushing That Homeless kid's face
or whatever and you were like
mentally ill yeah remember that you and
Logan were just slapping the out of
that so the kids really really
trying me so you know at the end I'm
like I pull out my credit card so I'm
like all right can you stop now my
credit card's out and the people in the
store they're like oh you guys aren't
together you got like you got to stop
you got to leave so they put them
outside and now the kid's filming from
outside really trying to get a reaction
out of me you streaming this like like a
live streamer just phone out I don't
know what he's doing at this point but I
know that he's going to film me walking
out so I walk out I'm like all right
nice meeting you guys and I don't think
anything of it I'm like a little pissed
off but I'm like cool it's over
with I hear footsteps running up behind
me it's the kid the kid chased
me down I don't know what the he's
going to do so I at that point I grab
him grab the phone about to
start blasting him with the
phone cuz now he's really like coming to
attack me this is self-defense at this
point now I got this phone in my hand
and the kid pulls out pepper spray to
try and spray me I've hav been
sprayed before so I'm not trying to get
sprayed again that shuts you you
ever been pepper sprayed no I got the
phone I've seen Joey salads be pepper
sprayed and that did not look fun at
all I got the video I got it
deleted and then the kid was trying to
pepper spray me and I got to get out of
there on on foot I got to use all my
training it felt really nice to use a
little Jiu-Jitsu and then just
get out of there safely nobody was
harmed and it was nice I actually got to
teach one of those IRL streamers a
lesson none of us was harmed you get
what I'm
saying and it was like I think we need
more people like that in the world
because these people are a menace to
society they're going out and just
with people for their own
personal gain and profit like himself
well I didn't catch that first time I we
need more people in the world like yeah
well Jeff I don't know if you know this
but a prankster was literally shot in a
mall and almost everybody was like yeah
that guy so I don't I don't think
there's a lot of sympathy for these
people in the world but just the the
fact that it's this girl's boyfriend
how bizarre is that I go back to the
beginning bizarre you heard my situation
where that kid should I tell that story
about what happened he was IRL streamer
yeah yeah yeah so um I was out a couple
week or like a month ago now I'm out at
the store and this girl she's like oh
you're Jeff Whit oh my God I'm the girl
that made the eye statue for David still
weird cuz you know that she knows by now
we T it was talked about a lot yeah so
she's like oh I'm the one that made fun
of your that dve
slammed you into a
tractor and I'm like cool like oh yeah
that's great work she was like oh I know
like I felt bad like after I saw the
comments like I should have made it for
you or enough of this scorn it's too
much she said I should have made it for
you oh that would have been nice that's
basically the same as getting as undoing
uh the
accident um and as she's doing that that
whole interaction her boyfriend pulls
out the phone and starts filming me and
like trying to troll me he's doing like
an ey L stream
so
we what do you think about that um we
kind of started looking into this guy
did we find anything interesting about
him not really like he's not a a popular
streamer or anything um but I had never
heard of him before but I I I I wanted
to see if he had streamed this incident
but uh I wasn't able to find it anywhere
so I don't think so it wasn't streamed
as I I did talk to Jeff about it and uh
it wasn't
streamed
but that's why she worked with David
she's dating a wannabe Dollar Store
version of him interesting people need
to leave Jeff alone unrelated the wood
stain looks so much better okay thank
you that is unrelated you're
right I should have stopped it
unrelated wait Jeff is saying the
boyfriend of the girl who made the I
sculptor did it that's nuts why would
she be with someone like that I know she
seems to be like a somewhat
an artist of some repute like she has a
following I think and she's with this
psychotic
freak it feels like it's just weird do
you think she like knowingly
participated in she was there right and
giving and giving David an eyeball
sculpture because he hurt his friend
like do you think that she was in on the
I think she cuz if she was then that
makes sense that she's dating someone
her thing is she makes eyes right that's
but he commissioned her I think she
probably didn't care I mean but which
but to go up to him and say hey I did
that now is pretty weird yeah she sounds
like she kind of may be so that's what I
was saying at the beginning when when we
originally heard that story I thought
you know on her part it she was probably
unaware and unwitting participant to
this kind of trolly Behavior but hearing
this story I don't
know semi's Channel I was scanning
through there and it was quite
bizarre weird weird stuff there's like a
whole live streamer underbelly and I
think what Jeff is advocating if I can
read between the lines is a um Armed
Force of roaming goons who will
basically shoot on site
anyone that um could be perceived
as a live streamer do we agree or
disagree with that and that's not M Jeff
said that I want to be clear about that
violence I don't
endorse thoughts roaming Squad a death
squad no probably not a good idea I
think that's what Jeff meant when he
said more people like
me all well he explicitly was
saying uh there should just be more M
out there more Jeffs the world needs
more Jeffs that's that's true yeah be
more like me and less like you okay it's
always good
advice all right that's all I got to say
about
that
um you know what I want to do right
now what you don't think I should watch
this guy's videos Dan you can say it on
stream it's fine I again it's just like
he's he's a nobody exactly so I I don't
know I don't I don't want to necessarily
I mean I saw him streaming to like 2,000
people today so I mean he has some fans
but
that's 2,000 I mean how would you rank
that love uh on Kick might as will be
100 who knows that's true oh
true kick that's true the numbers are
not cuz his YouTube views are not no
he's like no followers no subscribers I
don't know he might have been hosted by
someone too I like who knows yeah all
right you know what I want to do so
we'll skip
him here's what I want to do since we're
in the actually no we have the Boogie
thing I really want to watch that
mhm that's in the title too so we got to
get to that let's do the Boogie
thing and then I want to watch the more
fous podcast Clips well and then we we
got to talk about Ryan this is like the
funniest story we have okay I better I
got to get focused there thank you sorry
I got to spit this out that must be so
annoying to listen to so for the fidus
we just have one as of now because it
was I don't know it's kind of I think we
need to make like compilation of them
because going to the it's just like him
sleeping through half of these podcast
so it's fine it's it's probably best not
to even show
it just a little freak no I'm talking
about videos videos he's a big freak I
think let me show a clip at least can
you we actually fidus had xqc on his
podcast yeah I can't believe he got him
it's a big pull um well he's a huge
YouTuber you have that uh clip Zach I do
yes would you like me to roll it yes
please when uh when you have multile
relation no multile Rel I mean a
say
seen what it's interesting I had you and
then I was with h anything wrong with
stre had to build constructive but just
pict arti with t across what it's
interesting it's interesting how you
compare like it like did you have
this as well how talking just mean yeah
you're not following are they understand
each
other excy kind of popped off yeah that
was funny it was interesting Fus was
right about that it was interesting oh
here sorry here's a visual go ahead
guys when when you have multi relation
no multi relation Ian a says
is it's interesting I had you and then I
was had to building constructive but
just wi Pi artist with t across it's
interesting it's how you compare like
it like did you have this as well I
love how much effort puts into his
podast like you can't even be up
pronunciate like even his voice is uh
taking the day
off where is that I don't see it in the
doc the F
stuff to of the show number eight oh
thank you or I'm sorry Goofs and gaps
number eight Goofs and gaps number right
thank you here it is I I'm sorry I got
to I Love It here he is move over Larry
King this was posted on the subreddit I
guess he's with his ex-girlfriend is
that the premise
yes all right let's take a
listen I'm sure it's going to be really
interesting
advice it's
interesting when uh when you have
multiple relation no multiple relation I
mean I had you and then I was with Olia
it's interesting how you
compare how will say in his
defense excuse well actually no I guess
they both are not native speakers so I
guess they should both they both do get
a kind of a pass
but his English is good I mean I've seen
him speaking before but you know he it's
not his first language he's Greek so so
we give him a pass for that well and in
this I think the uh especially mumbly
aspect in this case is because he's T
having a very awkward conversation with
the ex-girlfriend yeah the mumbling I
don't think you can blame on the that
that on top of uh the foreign language
foreign language or second language I
had you and then I was with Olia it's
interesting how you
compare how you comp when another new
person potentially comes in the your
life it's like you compare what if we
did is she more beautiful is she more
cool is she more loving is
she like did you have this how is I did
the trail off he's
awesome I am obsessed with
video um here let's
find I got to go to his channel yeah you
can just go to any moment and it's just
so good when you have let's see mul Rel
what they learned from their
relationship good oh this has 100,000
views that was a big hit for him yeah
ific fandom what if you ever hit rock
bottom you're going to regret giving
this girl up man hard to find someone as
genuine as her especially in your field
of work oh oh bro you better get her
back she's an angel oh there's
hardcore advocating for this girl is
gold beautiful soul and so brave wow
fous it's interesting it is the comments
are
surprising let's see what did they learn
from the relationship of
see
how if you met other people how you felt
when we probably s had a girlriend for
some time how did that go and how I also
appreciate that it's called Blitz which
implies some kind of quick movement
quick attack right so this was uh I was
very confused by this because there's a
blitz
podcast which is uh he also is on that
channel Chan sometimes um but is
actually a separate podcast but he must
have just used their set to film this
for whatever reason oh so he's not
associated well he is but uh the blitz
podcast uh is in uh Greek or at least
oftentimes there's other hosts uh it was
I don't speak Greek so I wasn't exactly
sure what was going on but you might say
It's Greek To Me It's Greek To
Me
yep uhhuh another Zinger brought to you
by Ethan Klein sh Shakespeare said that
I believe it's a Shakespeare quote
mhm it's
interesting what your current
status people want to
know oh sopia
don't um wait I'll answer it like I try
not to be not everything needs to be
recorded I
think I mean this was a hit for him
though true true the part how did make
me feel when I saw you had a girlfriend
it helped me go get my bike sounds very
funny but I will explain the
story I I moved to the new she does seem
really nice and wholesome I'm not
interested in that his questions seem
like the way they're worded they seem a
little bit like they would hurt my
feelings the way he's like you know you
compare like is she more beautiful than
you like what are you talking about
don't say that to me right now
and how did you feel about my
girlfriend right she and I always think
is she hotter is she funnier than you
and I think yes she is what the and
that's why I'm glad I left you pretty
it's pretty rough is I'm so happy we had
this conversation it is interesting
people are pointing out that uh the font
of Blitz makes it look like it says
butts
God I did not catch but they're
right got podcast
uh naturally and I was like hm maybe I
was wrong and maybe it just needs time
for you to um learn personalities yeah I
think that's I think that's what they
mean see I told you multitasking is not
a thing what did I
[Laughter]
say I'm trying to find the next CR but
that's that's not nice because when
people are speaking to you they have
have your full attention then you can be
like give me a sec that's fine and then
you can just read and then haven't seen
here's the problem I they're having a
genuine conversation and I love that for
them I need to find these newer ones
that like these are the ones I'm really
interested so what I've two days ago two
days ago 300 views
yeah you know podcasting is hard that
Banner is it's hard the one that I
really was interested in is his Clips
channel that seems to be AI generated
can I get a
link that uh yeah that was by far my
favorite second um what is interesting
about this podcast however is um I found
on one of his channels a uh he did like
a TED Talk Like thing about his
experience making that um Elon Musk
video where he camped outside of Tesla
headquarters well that's what what was
interesting from that is he says in this
talk that Elon muskus is here and he's
watched all of his podcasts uh 10 times
or more and Elon is the reason that he's
into philosophy and um science and all
of these things and you'll see on his
podcast he is actually acting on that
all of the podcasts are like learning
the history of Napoleon or talking about
uh nihilism and like and they all have
like 150 views and it's just he gets
some Professor to come on and talk about
Napoleon for two hours and he just does
his nodding thing he doesn't talk here
here's what's so interesting he has a
big main Channel with lots of views yeah
so he he writes these people and he puts
that channel as an example of who he is
and he can probably get fairly uh people
whose time is fairly valuable onto his
show they seem like reputable academics
and stuff yeah and then they're G to
you know spend a few hours of
their precious time and it's going to
get here I mean two through two hour
three hours two views
oh my
god um yeah about reforming the
educationstem I'm dead serious this is
from four days ago 134 views 28 views
how is that possible let me watch this
one 28 views it's interesting it is okay
so give me some uh so this one has 28
views so let's see four
days advice I want to start from
tomorrow should I start I will get a a
simulator I will get a I will read your
book uh what else I should start
doing he
seems he seems hyper engaged bro is
tapped out he's been enough yapping I
like oh this the the the guest might
assume they're being trolled at some
point uh what else I should start this
is pretty great
here I think you should read the book
you should get a simulator and and uh
try to watch trade some traders who
trade live and learn from them for you
know one or two weeks to learn exactly
their thought process like for example
if you want to learn how to play chess
it's good to go and look at the people
who are playing the chess and ask them
why did you play that and the thought
process behind it so read the book there
are free simulators don't pay for it go
to trading terminal.com has a free
simulator go trade for Real Time for
free whatever dude let's see what this
lady has to say unlocking your sexual
Freedom oh I'm sure he's going to have a
lot to say about this wait who question
is what is some advice that you give for
normal
people
watching not that free sexual they're
not as expressive not open to sex I need
his insights on sexual Freedom
absolutely
crucial the question is what is some
advice that you give for normal people
like me and the people watching which
they are not that free in their
sexuality and that they're not that
expressive and that open to sex like uh
you
okay well I mean that can be various
things I don't even know what you mean
by that like does that mean that you're
just s in other words really good
question she's like I actually don't
know what you're want me to say which is
okay I mean you going to listen to your
own heart I'm not going to hear impress
anybody to be more open or less open
about stuff you know that's up to you to
decide interesting W that's a good clip
good clip it's really it's basically him
asking for uh advice and her saying no
and he uploaded that it's
interesting it is dude this one
has
12 this one has 12
views online all throughout the day
until I go to sleep so I'm always
answering yeah I'm always answering me
messages on only fans or any of the
other um apps that I'm on um I do not
answer DMS on public social media so
trying to write me on Instagram it's not
going to happen if you try to write me
or Twitter or any of those other places
I'm not going to respond back to you um
I only respond back to people that are
on my only
can I rewind these fans that are
subscribed to me or on my Sex Panther
that oh Jesus I work
online the day the
URL I spend so much oh right I work
online all throughout the day sorry
there was just a scene I saw that no
didn't
work uh you have to then type in here I
can do it I can do
it I work online
all throughout the day until I go to
sleep so I'm always answering yeah I'm
always answering me messages on only
cook a meal God damn it I work online
all throughout the day until I go to
sleep so I'm always answering yeah I'm
always answering me messages on only
fans or any of the other um apps that
I'm on um I do not answer DMS on public
social media
so trying to write me on Instagram it's
not going to happen if you try to write
me or Twitter or any of those other
places I'm not going to respond back to
you um I only respond back to
people
fans is he there where are you
FID where is fidus where is
he big fit it's
interesting I know what software is adds
the Emoji and all that it's so bad
I tried it for the podcast it sucks of
course dude what the oh thanks
thanks Dan I know it's a little late but
no it's still worth it it's still good
this could be worth um capturing all
throughout the day until I go to sleep
so I'm always answering yeah I'm always
answering me mes answer DMS on public
social media so trying to write me on
Instagram it's not going to happen if
you try to write me or Twitter or any of
those other places I'm not going to
respond back to you um I only respond
back to people that are on my only fans
that are subscribed to me you know I'll
I don't know if he's a a bad dude I
think he's just a little no he seems
fine his heart I think his heart is in
the right place he just doesn't
understand sometimes that what he's
doing in his social experiments is
really
up oh wait he took a sleeping back from
stole sleeping B from a homeless person
that was he gave it back he gave it back
it okay he took it for a night back the
next morning yeah
when it's interesting I just find it f i
mean this guy I'm on his Channel right
now nine months ago 13 million views on
a video and he can't swing like 28 views
on a
podcast I don't think conversing is his
strong
point I mean I I I guess you can admire
his persistence it's true it is true I
you know I I'd be interested to connect
with fid big FID yeah
I like him I want to enter his
mind there has to be some I I think it's
a send him to fist
Fest oh no guys we have tragic news
about fist Fest so we are trying to get
Sam and Olivia to go do the reporting
there and we got we heard back from the
council and they have decreed no girls
allowed literally devastated no
girls allowed at fist Fest man with the
I was speaking to the one of the heads
of fist Fest um the behinds maybe even
the behind yes uh and they went to the
council with the help of hunger who I I
just want to say they they've been more
than helpful with this stuff um yeah
Sweet People good people really very
good people um but yes we they said no
females so we need to find who who's
going to step up I think we have our
answer who Fus
God God this interesting just like how
don't do you like like hunger like got a
dude like two dudes like like a shoulder
deep that's interesting how do you do
this online how do you do it online it's
interesting Larry King rest in peace
still a better when when you have multi
relation no multi I
uh-huh even dead Larry King I think is a
better
interviewer oh I don't know if he beat
you up for it but I I'm seeing a lot of
people in the chat suggesting uh we send
Tom
wart oh my God wait that's a good idea
oh he he already said he would do it did
he mention that yeah he had mention I
saw him right somewhere that he would be
interested okay okay so wait oh my God
interesting online oh my God
it's interesting yeah it's genius
interesting my vote's still fous but Tom
would be I mean f um it's a long shot
fidus is kind of a menace and like we
like the fist Fest people he's going to
like steal their Lube
yeah whoever gets to go I'm going to be
so jealous I'm sorry Olivia I thought
you girls were going to do so great I
really tried I know I'm so grateful but
I understand it's their world it's their
rules so let's say Tom Tom Ward can we
who's in Char who's in contact with
Tommy Boy I am oh this is actually so
exciting it's going to be a very
emotional passing of the Baton but it'll
happen Wow Let's uh let's hop on a call
with him and maybe we can talk to the
guys with the F Fest too wow wow wow
that's
exciting it's
interesting yeah very very do you guys
want more fidus or is we do we do we got
to talk about our other two headline
stories before we run out of time and
then I was with it's interesting how you
compare yeah how you Com when another
new person potentially comes in your
life it's like you compare
what is she more beautiful is she more
cool is she more loving is
she like did
you
right I don't know jackass is she
telling tell me that's what I would say
if my boyfriend said that to me true
it's
interesting all right let's talk about
buggy 2988 who let's be real we've had a
little bit of a falling out with us
recently you might
say
um we were friendly with him for a while
he was a frequent guest on the
show it's been a long time since he's
been on the show
but all of the sudden he started just
posting like mad Ethan hate
like just the
hardcore he Boogie even Boogie did a fat
man bad to
me
Boogie and so I was like dude what the
is your deal man like everybody on
the internet hating me and now you're
like just joining it seemed to me he was
just hating for attention
which whatever and I just said one thing
I was like listen Boogie this shit's
lame whatever and he's he's lost his
mind he doesn't stopped talking about me
um so that's the status of our
relationship and
clearly he has not been doing
great um his views have fallen off
really significantly actually let me go
to his
channel I included some uh screen grabs
that show his analytics yeah um it's
it's interesting interesting it's
interesting it's interesting this is
from the documentary
so let's see he's
apparently if you yeah so he shows views
and then income from
YouTube he was complaining that he
doesn't have enough to live on he only
gets $3,000 a month in YouTube Revenue
scroll down
yeah he only made 26 Grand in 2022 from
YouTube and according the documentarian
said he had access to his bank
statements right so this is how did it
fall off that hard that's well he that's
crazy he really wasn't let's look at his
channel he get no no views no views he I
thought he had like hate Watchers that
would at least you know juice some juice
some views like he that's crazy I I
don't know if a lot of people were just
super grossed out with the girlfriend
the super young girlfriend thing too
he's milking the dock now though he's
he's like clicked B in his his like
20-year-old girlfriend who looks like
she's 15 Boogie's girlfriend speaks up
girlfriend tells her truth about Boogie
he posted that on his own
channel um but if you go back to
2022 let's go back here the other thing
I've noticed is he just doesn't post
that much um I guess that'll do it like
here let's go back back back back
back I'm kind of
curious okay so yeah I mean you're
getting like 20,000 views per video and
you're uploading like one or two videos
a week yeah I guess that's pretty much
zero money I see in fact it's almost
certain that the majority of that is
coming from his old
videos you
know
um trying to see what other content he's
making let's see dating guide for fat
men m mhm it's
interesting my response to this dude
made a video about him y whatever so
it's been hard times for him it is funny
to me that he in the documentary again
he he lives in Kansas what I I'm
assuming Arkansas sorry sorry Arkansas
which I'm assuming the the cost of
living there is significantly lower than
uh most places in the United States
so he's goes yo I only getting $3,000 a
month I can't live I need 7,000 a month
to survive I was like the
seven he needs 7,000 a
month that's a lot of money isn't it
Arkansas is uh the cost of living in
Arkansas is 8% lower than the national
average so I it's on it's in the bottom
bottom half okay not that I guess it's
not sign ific but it is definitely
cheaper I don't know cuz my my
perception is all crazy cuz I live in LA
I don't know what it's actually cost
California is 42.8% more expensive than
Arkansas so it's double or I mean no 50%
more for everything
mhm so 7,000 there would cost I need
15,000 a month to
live no that's double more like 10,000
anyway the documentary was really good
frankly I watched the whole whole damn
thing and um it's an hour long I wanted
it to be longer I thought it was so good
and I thought the guy who made the
documentary is Mega talented he really
put in the work
to to do the he really did a a really
good uh piece of of film I don't know
his name is Mike Clum Mike Clum it was
pretty wonderful and uh I'm I'm very
impressed I mean he really spent time
out there with him too like he he really
immersed himself in Boogie's world I
wish it was longer Mike that's my only
regret I mean the look at the intro I
mean it's really well produced when I'm
on my death back is this you said
there's claims all throughout the video
the timestamps that I added are okay
okay yeah so I won't watch it but there
are certain time stamps that are so
phenomenal that I need to share it with
you guys but I do recommend watching the
whole thing it's very good
um let's see so this guy Mike Clum was
with him for nine
months and he had full access to his
day-to-day schedule personal contacts
and financial statements and it's kind
of
Mike I know Boogie is probably doing it
just for the attention but it is kind of
admirable that he gave him that level of
transparency
right in in the service of making a good
documentary
the mic
so here is Boogie talking about how his
net worth is
zero here he is in the bathtub
uh and on top of that something up I see
you guys Whispering back there oh no no
I just there was there's that other
bathtub scene that I don't know if we
can show I wasn't sure if that's what
you're referring to you know can we can
we a lot of skin no no I mean you can't
see your butt you mean you see like the
top of the butt you could speak it out
like a fanfic and explain it yeah she
got off it's such an important
scene by the way where's the food at Sam
were we getting an ETA on
that hi you might be out getting it
right now I'm going to hope for that oh
that's so true Mike oh Mike Clum just
donated 400 bucks you didn't need to do
that oh Mike's Mike is uh in the
audience H podcast thank you all for
reacting to the film number one podcast
on the planet that's right he knows my
next documentary answers the world's
most Googled question does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like
Harvey that is great news wow Mike
turn I got to say Mike I I think this if
I look at your channel cuz I was real
curious cuz I I really am a fan of your
of this video it's the only one he's
made so he just hit the scene hit hit
the scene running I think he's got a
bright future as a documentarian he he
really did something special is is he
perhaps already a documentarian that
just was not um on YouTube you want call
like actually doing like film festiv
call in let's talk to Mike that' be good
tell him to send me a DM DM Olivia on on
Instagram Olivia Lopez with an S Olivia
Lopes Mike you said Lope
I that's how I say to spell it it's
easier like envelopes lope s but with an
S so Mike DM Olivia
Lopes on Instagram I would love to get
you on the call get it straight from the
horse's mouth as they say yeah he said
the description says thank you for
checking out my first documentary oh on
this platform on this platform see I I
cuz the uh the quality of the production
does not seem it's not amateurish at all
all I have a feeling he's he's done some
other
work anyway here
here's here's the
scene I stole
$163,000 on my house I think my net
worth is zero Once you pull the equity
out of the house get rid of the house
debt sell off on my
collectibles and pay off all my debts I
think that puts me at $0
[Music]
I'm
worthless love is dogs though yeah this
is the hard part back to real Shredder
used to do that so cute I had a dream
about Shredder last
night so
unfair let's go to the next
clip uh I'm being careful because I
don't want it to get claimed yeah I'll
I'll stop you before gastric bypass
breakdown aftermath and why he wants to
save 20K to remove access skin all of
the claims said no effect but just to be
safe is said no impact at all oh that's
fine then well it might be different
it's yeah it's it's got me in Zach
couple times Well if if they change it
up I'll just dispute it okay you know
because I I want if he calls in you can
ask is this royalty free music he
actually is going to call in well listen
it if it's royalty free or not is none
of my concern as a commentator that's
that's right update I see Sam walking in
with bags oh Sam oh oh Mike you're going
to have to wait we got to eat Sam we
love
Sam fous you
hungry you want anything fous it's
interesting when when you have multi
relation no multi relation I mean you
and then I was
it's interesting how you compare there's
something in his ears you he how you
comp all right let's watch let's
continue despite a gastric bypass boogy
continues struggle with his weight I
mean he did lose a lot of
weight he is attempting to save the
$20,000 to remove the excess skin but my
best
feature this is the one the ladies love
I call it this was a lot my meat a apron
I have
two meat curtains there's a second
one I have two
glorious I this made me really I don't
like showing it to it's like it's like
it's not his private but it feels like
it is I've never seen anything like this
in my life and it's is that not a FAA
bro I don't I mean I guess technically
but I've never seen independent flaps
like that flaps they I think that's the
actual like medically medically FAA
that's the
Tupa T the t wait hold on maybe that's
maybe that's the excess skin CU he was a
lot bigger yeah he was talking about
getting the excess skin uh remove way
around some meat also the just the term
meat curtain
was it's unsettling the likeing
it so that's why I'm going to die
alone
[Music]
well my real name so um let's
see boogie spent oh this was quite a
revelation he spent over $200,000 on sex
workers between 2018 and 2020 why why is
it the same shot it's just him getting
out of the bath every time I click a
link all right hold on let me reset here
oh no wait hold on let me
it's a good shot it is it's just what's
happening it's just him getting out of
the bath again I don't know give me one
sec I think sometimes when we do doc
checks sometimes it copies over that's
the only thing I can think of
because yeah anyways here it is it's
uh right here there you go God bless
thank you we're pretty
sure join the lobby by the way if you
want me to bring them in let me finish
this clip tins with sugaring I got to
some La actually let me just m hang
on a sec I want to show all these clips
I like just to kind of introduce the
audience and then I I have a lot of
questions for you actually I think
that's cool we got back to the hotel and
I do regret to say that I slept with
bogie
2988 overall the experience and I don't
mean to Fat shame or anything but there
was rules upon rules upon rules and it
took me a lot of time to find a
stick
I am now married with two kids and
sleeping with Boogie is one of the
reasons I quit sex
[Music]
work she said she said thank you she
said she quit sex work because she slept
with boogie that's snarly what's worse
um I guess this is a meme this probably
isn't something that actually happens
thank you Sam you know people say oh
right she like when you're with a girl
and then she like becomes a lesbian yeah
right it's kind of like in that that's
another Trope so well it reminds me of
the joke that Jimmy always tells i d
he's I was with the prostitute I dropped
my pants she dropped the
price I Dro I dropped my pants she let
she dropped the indang her work her old
work fi oh yeah you're good oh
this is
spicy I don't do good with spice is that
sexist to me sure is that womanizing to
me sure I don't really care
um I'm a 48-year-old man I never got to
a model this let me a couple
of models is that
wrong it's not
wrong here we have some I mean I I don't
generally have I don't have a problem
with sex work if it's like done
ethically and safely and
stuff although I don't know what
happened in that room because this woman
did a 180 she changed her whole life
some of the women in this area that are
local and ready to go out they'll go to
dinner with you they'll go to a show
with you maybe they'll come back to your
place but they are expecting something
in
exchange uh but then it's window
shopping right like any other meat
market like Tinder you kind of scroll
down I hate how he talk about made me so
uncomfortable yeah that's not nice a
meat market that's very
up
Jesus Christ man sounds like human
trafficky let's get into a meat market
eh someone that looks interesting to
you I think this girl is really cute oh
yeah
yeah she's definitely a little thicker
than I necessarily would always go for
but there's nothing wrong with it that
blew me
away he says she's too fat for him
brother but but he's willing to settle
so it's
okay so I deserve to go to Disneyland
with a beautiful girl right I deserve to
go to to New York and explore Time
Square with a beautiful girl why that
was a part that a lot of people had a
problem with I deserve yeah like why do
you deserve
MH because he's boogie
2988 doesn't everyone deserve to have
sex with the model and go to Disneyland
I thought that was just basic human I
mean in the hierarchy of needs Dan and
I'm a I am a student of yeah yeah it's
up there as I think that was in the uh
second Bill of Rights actually mhm yes
mhm we talked about that a lot um this
salsa is so good spicy I'm dying
over here I'm like rushing to finish it
because it's so damn hot the red one oh
I guess they're all red there whatever's
on it I even I'm not even dipping it
wait there's a brown one too red
and I want that and I've never had it
man if I had that money
back that would be half of my mortgage
right now ,000 is my entire health
insurance
payment I don't know what the
prostitutes did with it and I hope they
spent it in in good health uh but I sure
could use that right now you
know you want to go for a walk so you
can you know I think that we might need
to Sound by this part Z man right like I
deserve that to New York so I deserve to
go to Disneyland with a beautiful girl
right I deserve to go to to New York and
explore Time Square with a beautiful
girl right like I deserve that and I
want that and I've never had it man if I
had that it is a
weird
statement I really do think there's
something where he he really genuinely
is like I'm boogie
2988 right he is really I mean he was a
big deal I mean it's but it's different
than saying like I deserve love I
deserve hot girls and going to
Disneyland everybody deserves love
that's not what he said right he says I
want to hot and go to
Disneyland that's a different
thing here he is trying to sell his
collectible cards to to uh
pay his rent or his mortgage
Leo I know how much these things mean to
you what's it like to have to sell them
to be able to live so selling off these
things kind of sucks because I've been
playing Magic for 30 years and some of
the cards in this box I opened back in
1994 I opened them in like '96 and I've
held on to them ever since and that's
like they're a piece of my childhood
they're a piece of my history I thought
I was going to get buried with this
stuff this is this is my stuff this is
me this is part of me and uh I made some
money off of YouTube last month but I
did not make enough without a sponsor or
something like that I just I'm not
making enough so we're going to go to
the game shop but this is going to keep
me from going out on the on the streets
right like this is going to keep me in a
house
so I think I think it's bittersweet I
think he would find it Bittersweet at
this place Boogie will be bankrupt in
six months
I'm selling magic cards on whatnot I'm
selling collectibles on eBay I'm selling
arcade machines locally I'll sell it all
and I'm going to sell enough to help
with I
think obviously being broke like that
and losing everything is horrible but I
think the the reason people don't feel
too bad for him is that it's so
self-inflicted mhm and it's come it's
been coming for so long
yeah I will say I brought a bunch of
like action figures from Michigan this
last time we went last weekend to
decorate my new office where uh meina
just moved and this documentary
me up cuz I'm like D I really want toys
in the background it just changed my
perception of it a little bit Yeah but
he he's not the only one yeah there's
lots of cool dudes with toys in the
background on
YouTube I mean I I sure I can think of a
few of them if you give me a day or
two I decided to throw out all my Legos
after watching all this boogie dog the
quartering has toys behind
him he's a cool
dude those things were a to pack
too
so the yeah the current D the pronoun
guy yeah he loves that kind of is
there anybody cool is there
anybody H H has toys There You Go he
does yeah he has some not a lot but has
more like just stuff back
there specifically political things yeah
all right I'm about to get a
bookcase behind me
now this like encyclopedia branica I
don't think there's anything wrong
though it just it reminds me of like
um John trones kind of content you know
what I
mean it's still real to me damage like
I'm going to review this video game from
1993 it's interesting that's the vibe it
gives
off so
mortgage
remember oh yeah let's bring go ahead
bring him on I I don't want to keep him
waiting there's a lot more Clips
um compilation of boogies dark
humor hey
Mike's up man how'd you do
this well I emailed Boogie and he
replied and then we did a zoom call and
uh
we were like two three weeks after that
so and did you have a budget or are you
doing this solo by yourself like what
what's the
process yeah so I I own a like a video
production company in Ohio and um I've
been shooting like documentaries for um
like corporations like training videos
and kind of all the corporate videos and
I've done some other YouTube shows kind
of like behind the scenes I would do the
the kind of the business side of it but
uh yeah I was just bored I wanted to do
something for fun I was scrolling
YouTube and saw that Sunny V2 video
right uh was like you know boogies claps
or whatever I'm like all right should I
make stuff like this but I'm like you
know not really so I was just like hey
if I took all my cameras and my my crew
and we kind of did like the liveaction
Cinematic followup to that could that
play on YouTube and that that
so wait it was you and how many people
were out there I had one shooter with
me um and then I I edited I produced it
and we had some assists in editing so a
team of three
wow and so you and you and and your
camera guy you guys went out and lived
with him for nine months right I mean it
wasn't nine months straight but we
filmed quite a few times you know I I I
couldn't have make it N9 months straight
uh that is a long time wouldn't have
worked wouldn't have worked but yeah oh
do you know Jimmy
Lee I do know Jimmy Lee he keeps calling
I get out say dude how does he have time
this man has so much damn time got them
tax there's tax let me read let me read
let me read holy first off how
Jimmy Lee spells please is PL PL call
yep y
uhhuh call with a bunch of L's important
call me period important so I I guess I
gotta call him back it's important no
you don't you want to call him right now
God no no no I'm not gonna call him now
Bas what happened was I filmed the
documentary with him too but the problem
is and I talked to him last week he kind
of went behind my back and made a whole
different documentary oh no he
did yeah so I mean I love Jimmy he you
know it was a I would have made a great
film I think but we were taking too long
on the edit because I had to get it just
takes a time I think he was very wait so
you had spent significant time with
Jimmy creating a similar style
documentary as boogies yeah maybe wasn't
as involved but we had spent we shot for
four days I love Jimmy he's probably
going to call me uh after this uh this
he we talked I talked after because he
put out this documentary it was it was
good I I think bring Jimmy on I have to
ask him I feel like he really up
and he didn't tell you he was working on
a documentary congruently because that's
a little that's a little until I saw the
until I but until I saw the trailer I
think he just wanted to move quicker
than I was able to move he is a very
hard worker uh you know and uh
unfortunately I don't know what I'm
going to do with all the footage now you
know can he literally remade the exact
scenes they went to the same
places it was it just wasn't I'm like
what am I supposed to do this is a
replica you know I was gonna say that I
I don't know because like first of all
the one that went out was good I enjoyed
it yeah but I am curious about because I
feel like your product is more polished
more professional no disrespect to the
other guy uh but but I would watch it
still yeah I I would check out I I
watched it and I'm like hey this is good
but it's basic it was basically pre-made
but FAS I couldn't have probably got it
out as quickly because we shot in like
July and or June and um it's you know I
probably would have it would have taken
me a year because this the level of
editing and if you have other projects
it just takes takes time espe I'm yeah
documentaries are are difficult and long
and hard love Jimmy Jimmy when you call
me I you're a great guy people love you
uh but unfortunately I don't know what
we're gonna do with this document oh no
you don't know so you must have lost a
lot of money on that just sunk time and
money into that it's mostly time I mean
the I I have some other businesses and
it pays for the travel and other things
that's good but I'm just doing this for
fun I mean obviously if it gets used uh
that's cool but I I started doing this
because I I I want to do do some stuff
for fun how are you feeling I mean the
it's really taking off 1.5 million views
I mean that's pretty tremendous for your
first yeah I mean video uh it's it's
just probably the most fun week of my
life honestly I
mean I was I I was thinking maybe pull a
few hundred K I know he would he was
going to promote it um uh and I I
thought maybe 250 300,000 would be cool
and then do another one and try to try
to grow uh but after Penguins dropped
his video it was like you know ah that
did a lot of movement for you yeah
um I there was one oh yeah Jim we
brought I had to bring Jimmy on sorry
Mike I had I I just have questions I
have to call him back I have to call him
back so this I mean you can do this
basically the two purposes you this is
you calling him back let's knock it out
let's knock it out he still call him
later oh I I have a question actually
Mike because the the doc hold on one sec
there
Jimbo okay
Jim
j the Jimmy how the do you
getting hold of every damn person in my
life and I just met this guy I didn't
even know this guy how what the
dude well he's a son's a cuz he
did the documentary and he didn't put it
up Mike
and Jimmy so I shot this and this dude's
calling me like the week later when can
we get it out can we ex I mean I'm like
I need time I need time and you know
dude you shot it like four months ago
and you didn't do nothing come on Mike
Jimmy dude come on hold on hold on these
things take time Jimmy Jimmy hold on you
really him over you know that
right Mike Clump was supposed to be my
buddy but he didn't he just didn't uh he
he didn't get the documentary out then
the other guy came in and he did it like
right away I'm not mad of you Mike we
had a we had a you know
try if
I do it still hold on one at a time Mike
go ahead go ahead Mike Jimmy I have no
hard feelings you did what you did I
think we're going to hold on to the
footage you're GNA the more famous you
get we'll drop this documentary in like
three4 years who knows what's going to
change in your life I don't know if
he'll be alive then listen Mike listen
why don't you just drop it now what are
we waiting for well Jimmy unfortunately
you replicated all the interviews and
the whole story arc that we shot uh with
this I'm not mad at it I'm not mad it
happens some you do a project you got to
turn it off but
uh you do a different angle do a
different angle yeah what kind of ankle
did you have in mind for him
Jimmy well if he watches the whole
documentary that Alex did he can just
use his footage and do a different angle
he has different stuff like he didn't do
my brother he did a lot more
unfortunately that's not how it works
that's not we were at the white now hold
on hold on we were at the White House
Sub Shop you interviewed cousin Freddy
Alex never interviewed cousin Fred you
have a lot of different stuff uh Mike
you really do uh hold on Mike Jimmy has
suggested that you use the footage from
the other documentary is that something
that you can do typically speaking best
practices for documentaries is to not
take from another documentary that's
generally Jimmy do you understand
that say it again do you understand that
it wouldn't really be ethical for him to
that's steal the other guy footage and
just pwn it off as his own no I don't
want him I don't want him to take
anything what the other filmmaker did I
wanted him to use his own footage
because he has a lot of different people
that Allan didn't do and he could create
his own story on me what do you mean by
your own story I want I need well
there's different people being
interviewed and we did different
locations we were at IL Molina we were
at the White House Sub
Shop Mike your
response hey I unfortunately think
Olivia I think Olivia will agree with me
on this Olivia your response Jim I don't
know if you want my opinion on this she
was crying at your documentary but I
think she's retracting those tears now
Jimmy no the tears tears were real and
tears can't be retracted just I don't
know Jim if I'm being honest I think
that you should have let him know that
you were doing another documentary it's
okay I listen it's okay Jimmy I love you
you're a great dentist you're a great
Entertainer and you're going to get
more famous you're GNA keep getting more
famous way down the road in my defense
uh Olivia I reached out to Mike several
times and I to do several hundred I
believe
that and he you know what that's like
and and he didn't he didn't do anything
and then this guy came along Alex and he
wanted to do it right away so I I did it
with someone who was going to do
documentary Jim you have to reckon
though with this uncomfortable truth
that you really did over Mike mhm
no I I really did because he
IED time and he didn't do anything hold
on hold on hold on Jimmy he came to you
he s he invested a significant amount of
time documenting it it's unrealistic for
you to expect him a serious
documentarian by the way I don't know if
you watched the one on Boogie it's
really really good it has 1.5 million
views how much does your documentary
have by the way you have 1.5 million
views Mike
yeah well then you have to do then you
have to do
[Applause]
my Mike it's a
no-brainer oh my God M only has
30,000 30,000 sounds May so do you see
what I'm saying though Jimmy he you
snubbed him and you should have at least
told him Jimmy that you were working
with another
documentarian okay well maybe I owe you
an apology maybe you're right
Ethan want to serious note and does that
apology have anything to do with how you
learned how many views that his
documentary
[Laughter]
got say that again does the apology you
just gave him have anything to do with
your discovery of the amount of views
his boogie documentary
got well I didn't know anything about it
till you told me but but I had reached
out to Mike even earlier today before I
even knew you were even going on to call
me because my documentary is out and I
wanted to ask Mike if he wanted to to do
mine so this just came to me just now so
no answer I apologize because maybe I
should have because maybe I should have
told you Jimmy go ahead Mike go ahead
Jimmy was very poite of you to call me
to ask me if I wanted to complete the
document
uh however given the fact that uh the
other documentary replicated all the
scenes we shot uh unfortunately I don't
think there's enough original content to
make this engaging so I do think we have
seems fair well let me seems let me ask
you this did you shoot with MZ
boss that's there there were certain
things that just curious just curious I
wasn't yeah Jimmy by the way I don't
think Ethan he met mozzarella boss I so
may so well
maybe well oh my cut to Jimmy's
camera um I would say that Mike might
have an interesting vertical with M's
boss but that was actually already done
by the other guy
right
hi Jim all right well well Jimmy
unfortunately Jimmy unfortunately I hate
to tell you but I really think you
missed your moment here and I got to
tell you another thing I think you're
really blowing it with the Bobby Lee
thing and I I'm trying my best man but
uh it's just you're making it very
difficult for me to to turn you into a
star now I I wanted to apologize because
I had given Zach dates and I just I
couldn't come out but I'm trying to come
out I'm trying to come out the first
week of December Mike you know about
this
story I'm not familiar I I I yeah so
Bobby Lee is a friend of mine I texted
him and I said please do me a personal
favor and have Jimmy Lee on your podcast
he says okay I'll do you I will do that
for you Jimmy Lee now as we're trying to
schedule it has told us
that it's not worth coming out here just
for Bobby's show because he's not big
enough oh Bobby Lee is not big enough
listen the Jersey Outlaw he's got a lot
going on he's running multiple Dental
practices he's a com he's got to be
selective on who he books with and Bobby
Lee frankly just may not be at that
repertoire he he's on let's be real
Bobby Lee is not what he used to be in
terms of uh you know actually that's not
true I feel like Bobby's more famous now
or more kind of cool than he's ever been
despite being like
60 Jimmy I would highly recommend going
on the Bobby Lee
show that's probably I will go on if can
they get can you get me on Ethan the
beginning of December this is what you
can't comprehend for some let me
lay it out for you Jimmy they they had
certain dates that were available you
offered some dates they went back it
it's just not working out I told them I
apologized to them I said you know what
maybe let's just try again after after
the new year and uh yeah it's it's it's
more of a when they're available type of
thing and can you I understand can you
pleas just please comprehend this that
they this is how it is I know you've
been reading comments to get you on
Bobby but it the time does not work the
the the opportunity I get it it's not
going to happen I got you Z all right
very cool cool so um well listen I hope
I'm gonna keep talking to Mike I'm gonna
say goodbye to you Jimmy I hope you guys
before you say goodbye to me could you
put a good word in the mic to maybe do
the documentary maybe in the
fure sure Jimmy maybe Zach could talk to
him uh yeah I'll do Mike um what do you
think Big Mike what do you think Big
Mike a free sub at the White House Sub
Shop
Mike free the White House two on the
house oh I'm in Jimmy I'm in well let's
go come on buddy a free mozzarella
lesson all right listen Jimmy Jimmy I'll
call you you're listen you have an
amazing career ahead of you uh and do
this is
just I love you I love you Mike I hope
you're not mad at me I love you too
Jimmy I had fun filming and those will
always be great memories all right all
right budddy love you guys all right
Jimmy Jimmy where are you Jimmy by the
way guys thanks for all the love on
Monday where are
you a restaurant called ad birdies but I
had to go in the back it's too noisy
wait where did he say bir I'm at an
Italian restaurant CH Hill having dinner
called ad dud I love that like I feel
like you're in a restaurant like 80% of
your
day it's really good here yeah I see all
right J uh we'll talk soon I'm sure
peace and love guys love you all right
peace and love love you bye Jimmy all
right leave it off the screen for a
second bring keep M on call all right
byebye what the hell man I cannot
believe that Jimmy somehow is ingrained
himself so like how does he do it I
don't know and M Mike you're you're a
you're a saint for the grace that you
handled that with I don't think I could
have been nice oh Jimmy's great Jimmy's
great you just have to know how to set
your boundaries uhuh uh you got to hit
the can I call you later and just let
the 15 15 T learn but Mike Mike here's
the up thing you're gonna get
five more calls from him probably about
15 minutes you and we have mute we have
mute we have mute the
text that's what we do just and we move
on we keep it the thing is
when dealing with jimm Z I agree with
Mike mute the text mute the calls and
then when you want to talk to him you
reach
out because Jimmy would be on the phone
with you 247 if you'd let him yeah I
knew something was up when I I called
him to give him an update on the project
and and he didn't pick up because I was
like hey boogie and I'm like and then I
texted him and I got left on red I'm
like something is fish going on Jimmy
Lee is not calling me and answering my
my text I mean either that or he died I
saw the poster and you know so but
everyone go check
out check out the Jimmy Lee documentary
Alex did a great job and uh it well told
for what a guy well as you said uh as
his Fame grows the demand for this
documentary will only increase so let's
get back to Boogie though
um if you have a minute fre feel feel
free to you know sign off if you have if
you have
something um I want I just wanted to
watch a few more Clips so I'm going to
continue to do that and then I want to
ask you some questions about the time
you spent with him um oh I wanted to ask
you something the documentary doesn't
exactly paint him in a good light were
you
concerned about how he was going to
react to the film especially considering
he was probably the main uh promoter of
it at the
beginning yeah I for me when I first hit
him up from the first call it was pretty
I was clear like hey if we're gonna make
this it's it's going to be in the theme
of all of these other videos that are
assessing you you know the sunny V2 the
the Christopher Tom type you know kind
of takedowns not in a sense that he's
not to have a shot to tell his story but
the whole point of it was to try to tell
an accurate thing I have spent my whole
sort of corporate life uh you know
marketing Brands and things so I I I was
not interested in helping him do any PR
that certainly wouldn't have been
interesting uh at all yeah yeah so uh
and and we were so I I basically told
him as we're shooting and then as I'm in
the edit hey this is kind of what's
making the this is the sort of the
different chapters this what we go into
so by the time he watched the final
thing he was pretty well in the loop of
what that's smart you you set his
expectations uh in the right place from
the
beginning all right let me let me watch
through some of these clips here let's
see um oh God damn it Clos the
dock all right give me a sec here uh
Mike um I like to think this show is the
mike better run than Jimmy it's a it's a
Well oil machine over here at the a
Street podcast
uh sometimes my documents just closed
for no reason but we love
it mik so um I off that Mac and onto a
good computer like a Dell or
something okay it's not it's not loading
everything the okay what's
happening that's what was happening to
me last night when I was trying it
loaded all right so um this was my
favorite moment and I'm
sure a lot of people agree Boogie at a
certain point um under your suggestion
realizes that he needs to get a job and
uh he goes to a career counselor or was
it a recruiter recruiter yeah so this so
uh with the prospects of being hired and
this scene is really I think uh
tremendous nice to meet you my name is
da I professional staff what do you
prefer to be called honestly probably
Steve let's go with Steve okay Steve no
problem whatever you prefer and so you
are here today because you are seeking
employment yeah you're seeking out new
work opportunities absolutely tell me a
little bit about your background and
where you think you want to go with the
experience that you already have um I
did work at a small gaming store back
in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh recognized
by the state of Arkansas but also the
United States government there's that
now the downside to that is I am
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table and then physically I I am
morbidly obese I have no references uh
no work history and no education and
when you Google my name whatever you
prefer you might see rumors that I beat
my ex-wife and I'm also a pedophile
should mention I'm also F on me okay so
so what was your re reaction as you saw
that unfolding did you think he pitched
himself
good oh fabulously I mean how could you
not hire him after that but no really I
think um you know whenever Boogie just
doesn't want to get a job let's be clear
that's kind of yeah it's obvious and
when you bring it up to him even on a
one-on-one basis privately you know are
Concepts as he he does fixate on um is
there workarounds to the felony to the
obviously mental health or obesity or
whatever yes but he is so fixated on
them um and uh unfortunately I don't
think he'll ever get a job like that
sense I mean certainly not interviewing
like that but like you said I think but
I mean to just come out and be like yeah
so if you search my name I may have been
accused of beating my ex-wife and being
a pedop file like holy dude yeah
and I think like I had called this
random staffing company and I'm like hey
I'm filming this documentary with this
YouTuber in town so they had no idea who
this guy was they didn't really know
what we're filming so they they're kind
of taking it very seriously like this is
gonna be like this serious interview and
they're gonna it's gonna help make their
company look good because they're gonna
help them get a job and and obviously
she's just kind of what what's going on
so it was really the most awkward part
was it was almost kind of a prank on her
unintentionally right you start filming
and you're like oh he's in a he's he's
trolling uh he's trolling this so you
you think that that you think that
monologue of boogies
was how much of it was just sincere like
here I'm just a mess and or like I'm
just going to make a scene so that I
never get a job or maybe it's
entertaining for the
documentary uh I think it was uh
combination
yous of filming or whatever about a job
he will say the same same things maybe
not with the same punchiness and
delivery um but you know and to some
extent he has some points like it's
definitely hard would be hard for him to
get a job but because he's so fixated on
how hard it would be it's pretty much
gonna make it even wor but props to her
she was really professional throughout
she didn't even bad an ey um the next
thing I wanted to asked you about was
the his the part with his girlfriend who
she's 20 years old and Boogie is 49
although I have to say that she looks
extremely I think she looks even younger
than 20 was the filming this part
uncomfortable for you so much so in fact
there's a shot it appears that you're in
the room with them as they're um having
an intimate some kind of intimate
exchange yeah um it was it was so the
first first sort of half of the film the
guy's single and there's actually a
deleted scenes where I was trying I got
him a trainer uh I got him a dietician
we did a makeover I tried to get him a
girlfriend and and and and so there was
these in the Deep Boogie sphere there
was conspiracies that this was the
orchestrated girlfriend I got him ah um
but it wasn't so then he actually
started dating this girl in real life
and then I'm like okay well obviously we
have to put this in the dock so we we
back out and started filming um and yeah
I it wasn't that uncomfortable for me I
mean I think um you know it's part of
life and it it's I think sort of was in
entertaining if nothing else and uh it
it captured a a piece of reality that
they partake in so well as Taylor Swift
said love will find you when you least
expect
it that's true she's the only one that
has ever said that and and are you a
Swifty uh no uh I am not okay don't ever
admit that online don't take you want me
to button that out you retake that yes
please I actually
love huge fan we love
Taylor She's iconic okay so here's this
part with uh with his
girlfriend so this is uh this is
Desi you can call her Dez desire yeah
desire we've been just makes me so
uncomfortable couple months yeah and
they're still together right which kind
of surprised
me you yeah they're still together I you
I think some of the documentary sort
of uh hype has maybe th a little some
rockiness you know that the you know
there's the whole drama sphere of if
she's this paid uh you know person or
whatever ever and it maybe has caused
some Strife in their relationship well
we know one thing for sure he doesn't
have money to pay
her that's that's true uh he he does not
have a lot of money uh yeah that's
[Music]
true I just I don't know what it was it
was I guess this is energy his his curly
hair his glasses I'm I must be into
nerds it's I guess I don't know he's
just adorable to me I like him he was
going through a lot and I randomly hit
him up on Instagram and I told him that
I you know I support him and that I'm
always here for him and stuff and so it
it started from
there on paper it just doesn't really
add up right it doesn't make sense on
paper but then practice and
reality there was just something
there so it was pretty crazy but I just
felt it I felt felt an energy connection
to him before I even met him and I don't
know that's just so she she's living
with him full time
right yeah they lived together um I
think they moved in after maybe only a
month or so of of talking they met on
Instagram and they Snapchat Ed and uh
then she moved in and does she have like
I I guess I won't I won't probe too deep
into her is you know I mean she's she's
a sweet uh young person it seems like
and you
know really took me by surprise I don't
know different stages may or may not sat
around fantasizing about it and thinking
about you loved it say
yes that's a good
sign
Boogie has improved my life tremendously
so that just that you need and so it's I
help with the dog
I it makes it look better I used to have
a that I am a creepy
dude I found that person I'm trying to
find the sex scene it's up here right
yeah what yeah let me message you
something okay it's not really a sex
scene it's more of a a bathtub make out
scene let me ask you this is the
documentary green or
yellow uh oh for for me yeah it's it's
oh it's limited ads oh know it
then yeah I better not show it
all right well it shows them
basically getting it on in the tub and
were you there filming
it oh yeah I was there I I I was filming
basically everything and that was really
a culmination if you in the beginning of
the film then this was before this girl
was even part of the uh the situation
you he's talking about he's had these
intimate experiences in the bathtub and
these are some of the best moments of
his life that's kind of this you know
story that we introduced very early in
the beginning true
and when that opportunity came I'm like
hey if this is something you're doing
this is an activity you're sharing in
and this is how you express yourself
with your significant other as long as
it's not pornographic can we you know
film this and uh he he agreed that was
it was genuinely like a a great shot as
uncomfortable as it made me to like the
story how far did they take it with you
in there Mike did you have to excuse
yourself at some point or did you ride
the
coaster uh I wrote
uh there I there was no sexual
penetration uh or I don't believe any
sexual stimulation going on there
certainly was making out and laying on
the chest okay uh I can't say for
certain what they were doing under the
water I just don't think there was any
type of sexual activity so you you
weren't feeling uh yeah so I guess I
want to ask you broadly um oh no
specifically at the end maybe I'll show
it I quue you up because this this is a
great moment um when
he let's
see showed up you genuinely believe that
I can make a comp I did when I showed up
but I'm slowly
realizing that uh you're absolutely
okay all right
so and so this seems to be a genuine uh
observation of yours is is that is that
accurate to your experience with him
yeah yeah I mean in the certain way he
is uh but I do think you know
from
a in a variety of ways but I think uh at
times he really does have a positive
outlook um and he bounces between a very
very dire Outlook and a and a rational
positive optimistic Outlook and he
struggles a lot with anxiety and I think
the anxiety causes him to hyperfixate on
negative Fe back or negativity and then
he he'll bounce into a positive mindset
so I I was maybe playing it up a bit In
that clip you know just to kind of poke
fun at the situation but I do think he
has a future I mean he ultimately
whether his brand is loved or hated he
is a forever brand on YouTube definitely
very least everyone will think every
three to six months what's Boogie doing
and they'll go search his thing and
he'll always always pull 5 10 15,000
views even if that forever I think
that's true yeah I agree what was your
take on the whole boxing thing I mean
that was cool that that was included too
there was so much happening uh in the
documentary yeah I that was one of the
things we didn't hit too much on but it
was such a big event in his life that um
you know I had to put something in it's
it's tough when you're doing a film like
this like it's a such a long process and
when these quick events kind of pop up
and like well even if I go film it will
this be still that relevant right you
know four months eight months down the
road when I actually get this edit truly
done so I think I tried to focus on
stuff that was more Evergreen and more
relatable Beyond kind of a a one month
hype cycle do you have any plans to take
this to like a film festival outside the
YouTube sphere or anything like that
maybe I'm just having so it's just so
much fun to be able to put it out and
just see people's feedback like if this
was just on Hulu or something and maybe
I made a bit more money than I would
have the whole reason I'm doing this is
is to see the feedback and have fun with
it and and engage with people so you
know if I'm able to somehow create that
you know engagement through those but
honestly I'm really liking this project
I'm gonna keep doing this otherwise
um is there you've spent a lot of time
with him a lot of people hav't
obviously he has a reputation online was
there anything that surprised you about
being with
him um I mean he actually is someone
that is deeply
concerned about what other people think
about him and to his own detriment he's
actually a very uh a nice guy he it just
gets very anxious and um because he's so
concerned about what people think about
him he will try to convince you
otherwise um you know and to the extent
that back in 2017 2018 when there were
these little pockets of Reddit or maybe
someone did do a takedown video he could
just spend the whole month hyper
fixating on those things so I did I
think that the amount of visceral anger
people have towards Boogie and then when
you actually
spend a few hours with him or whatever
he actually is
a sweet nice guy um it's just that when
he gets alone and he Scrolls Twitter he
just gets you know kind of gets in these
mindsets of of of fight back the other
thing he's never really had even when he
was married he never really had a solid
PR manager business partner kind of
someone that could he could bounce those
ideas off of and and be like hey don't
put out a video about the Reddit or
don't put out a video clapping back
right so he would do a lot of things
that I think if he had that he had a
good kind of PR business manager back
then he'd still be the the Boogie that
we we
knew can you give us a glimpse are you
working on any projects at the moment
besides Jimmy Lee who has obviously been
canned yeah well there are some uh that
have started and have or have some
limbo I I getting the feedback I've got
on this you kind of realize the quality
it needs to be and
um sometimes you start a project and
it's interesting but I do have a few
that I I definitely could see coming out
and I have some other ones that you know
when I was hitting people up I'm like
hey I'm gonna put it on my channel and I
had no Channel I had zero subscribers
like true why would we do this so you
know and I don't blame them but now hey
it's like hey here's the proof of what
yeah you know I can do and and so I I I
could see a lot more but I do like the
biopic stuff but I I I definitely want
to do more that's you know General
topics down the road yeah is it is it
your focus on YouTubers or are you kind
of looking more
broadly I would say I mean to start I
felt obviously on YouTube it was it was
because I saw these super viral uh you
know just voice over
documentaries I I fig start in that
pocket but I'm not like really I love
YouTube but I'm not I couldn't see
myself making YouTuber documentaries for
forever so you know my goal would be to
to do this have some fun with it and and
you know see where it goes Mike I heard
a rumor that you were filming something
with Trisha
pis that certainly is it's confirmable
on YouTube she's got a video we did film
with
Trisha uh you know I know this is close
to home for you and maybe some family
and some other things so uh you know I
don't want to start any drama not at
all couldn't
possibly yeah the documentary went on
pause it had a certain angle and that
kind
of well I I hit her up to kind of do a
general biopic life I mean she has
obviously Trish is an interesting def
Dynam doubt yeah there's no question
like hey I was like you know and so part
of it was um you know so we filmed for a
week uh and and one of the big pieces
she wanted to hit on was this Reddit
that was in her defense and her defense
it was like 40,000 people that all they
did all day every every 10 minutes was
speculate on some specific thing about
her and her how she was
parenting I have no idea what that's
like
yeah you know so anyway we started
filming and we were kind of documenting
um and then basically in the process of
filming uh one of the scenes I sort of
directed was having her email Reddit and
you know put all the evidence in and and
email them and then I think a combin and
then inside of her Reddit there was all
these cross theories that I was against
her or for her or this was to do things
and then all of the people in her Reddit
started
[Music]
I don't know what is no there didn't
didn't we uh make friendenemies a 1200
at some point do we do we have a
friendenemies 10,000 I have Frenemies 12
oh it was
12 cuz it just the number kept going up
which ironically is as far as I can tell
a bunch of disgruntled Trisha fans who
are OBS they are probably some
of the most uh dedicated fans of the
show which honestly is is a good
thing her the Reddit though during the
process of filming uh got completely
obliterated you cannot make a Trisha
Reddit so it was like then good you know
it kind of came up that doing this
boogie thing and then it wasn't clear
whose Channel then it was going to go on
and then we kind we came to an agreement
but with just with everything going on I
I you know I'm not sure exactly where
the project will fall I Trisha's great
it was great filming with her it was
she's you know it was a genuine
experience but uh kind of the the angle
didn't it sort of stop so you keep I
feel like you keep running into some bad
luck like with the Trisha thing then the
subreddit gets fixed I mean obviously
that's good for her but bad for your
work and then Jimmy Lee just absolutely
double crossed
you it's a lot of rough goes Trisha
Trisha really didn't do anything wrong
that was kind of a mutual thing that it
it like whatever also for me I didn't
want to put out anything that wasn't
like hidden and really good so like if
I'm just going to put out something kind
of average it was like not as
interesting with Jimmy I think Jimmy has
this thing that he thinks and maybe it's
happening with the Bobby Le think he
thinks he can like override all other
people's processes to just expedite
things
immediately uh because he wants to move
quick and it this it unfortunately
didn't really work uh you know and um
you know I think he was just really
excited to get a dock out and had
probably somebody
[Music]
else
you nobody's laughing I'm going to
button it
out
what wait what you didn't laugh at a
joke you made well I thought maybe I
waso har I I don't even think it's a
joke I kind of think he thinks that yeah
well I'll let people uh guess
about wasn't anything that anyway got to
say I anyways I am a fan I think you are
a super talented dude and I really look
forward to to uh more uh projects from
you yeah and I this is so fun coming on
I remember I think it was 2015 I saw the
Tai Lopez douche uh triangle video that
pulled me into the sphere of of H3 oh
that's thank you you're a legend and I
you know it's so much fun thank you
that's nice we' love to hear it but uh
it just by the way it just went up from
1.5 to 1.6 so go I don't know where I
don't know where this video is going to
end up view wi but this is uh this is I
think it's got a lot of momentum I think
it's it's going to get up there you know
it's hard to find a good hourlong video
that's really high quality to watch on
YouTube so I have a question for you
though if who do you want outside of
Jimmy Lee obviously that would be a
great documentary if I made it what um
what who do you think I should do next
if you could pick anyone or connect with
anyone that you want to see I I will get
to work God I have legit so okay there's
this dude oh my God there's so many good
options I'm thinking first of all do
cman he is this
extraordinarily bizarre mysterious
endearing character he's a gay man that
makes um how do you spell it just C the
letter c man uhuh he he makes uh gay uh
homosexual pornography specifically
focused on feet and we found him okay
because we got a random ad on
YouTube it was a video of his bare feet
driving pushing on a pedal while driving
and the ad was do you want to be a model
in my foot in my foot and to be clear
it's specifically bare feet driving um
uh not not just like General foot porn
but like it has to be people like guys
in cars driving around pedal pumping
pedal pumping right it's called Barefoot
Brothers drive barefoot Brothers Drive
yeah and so we re we got a hold of him
after seeing this ad and there's this
whole world of seaman that is stunning I
think
I would I would die to watch an
documentary he's called into the show a
number of times Mike that would probably
be a good place to start because I don't
think that's probably the only place to
start really with uh his sort of public
appearances I'm Googling I'm trying to
find trying to find so undergr he's so
underground he he everyone in the
audience knows exactly what I'm saying
because he is a pro kind of a prolific
H3 character now but nobody know oh shoe
nice would be a crazy one too
oh wow he commented on the he commented
on the trailer I think Vice did
something with him back in 2015 there
might be a whole new arc I saw the vice
one but I don't I think there's so much
more to do right so much more to cover
with him yeah although he's a little I I
would be a little just I would be a tiny
bit afraid for your safety not like
fully but like he is somewhat
unpredictable he's sort of our Joker in
a way yeah oh man see wouldn't hurt you
he might come on your feet but he
wouldn't hurt you oh he'll come on my
feet that that's he'll definitely try I
think from what I understand about
him yeah but if but I don't know I if
you want I can send you some time stamps
of of our comos with him and I can put
you in touch C man shirt be great
shirtless Eddy would be a really
interesting one as
well um shirtless Edie hunger I've seen
that guy on yeah I've seen that guy
shirt Ed's interesting character I think
part of my part of my original Outreach
was sort of your I don't want to call
him wackpack but sort of
your yeah we'll get we'll get uh we'll
get sued if you call it that no I don't
like that because here here's what I
don't like the comparison I'm not saying
anything I want to make it clear though
because the wack Pack's a how Stern
thing and I feel like the people that he
brings on like that
he's way more I want to say
judgmental and rude to I I hope that we
have more of a
mutual respect uh and yeah somewhat of a
uh genuine interest in in these people
not so much just like oh you know what I
mean they're they're more like the uh
they're just orbiters they're H3
orbiters
right who did you reach out I had hit up
so there was Jimmy Lee uh and he got
back quick on it so that I was I I hit
up um whiteclaw Gabe good you know just
like what is going on what is this right
um who is it uh I tried to find the Joe
Biden uh what is this what does he
do he is so hard to find he would be
fantastic but I was trying to find
because I know you did a show with him
and there was like some kid that seemed
to kind of be his manager you know the
kid is in jail
jail yeah so we kind of lost he may have
embezzled the money we raised for him as
well I'm not totally sure I don't think
so cuz I have seen pictures of he wound
up with the car in a car so I think he
got a car at least no I don't I don't
think he I don't think he went to jail
for anything Wally related I think it
was unrelated crimes that he had
committed people are saying FY I hit
them up you
know yeah yeah so yeah I mean listen I
I'll be happy to put you in touch with
anyone I can uh that you'd be interested
in Patrice Wilson holy that'd be
nuts oh yeah that that would that would
be good I would do that you could
probably get a hold of him he seems like
someone that's trying to get the word
out about
the about the project I have so the one
I was I had the biggest one I was going
to be able to try to get before the
channel was started was uh steo and uh
we were talking and it was like this big
thing of whose channel is going on so it
I I I followed up with them today I'm
like hey my my new Doc got 1.5 million
view so steo I'm ready to do it uh he's
got a really cool think angle that that
we would come out with so that's true
you know um I'll put in a good word too
I'll text him and tell him that you're a
good guy and I think you guys make a
good
documentary well I I appreciate that and
uh I will credit you as associate
producer
executive
executive I'll text him right
now cuz I'm really bad at remembering to
do ship yo um putting in a good word for
Mike for Mike Clum yeah dude I'm not
trying to be that guy it is Clum uh with
it's all good you're not that guy listen
that's that's your name guy trust me
you're not that guy it's Mike
Clum uh super talented
documentarian the Mike he mentioned
wanting to do a doc with
you just wanted to put in a good word
and that will be executive produc
credits that's how it's done baby that's
Hollywood that's a little peek behind
the scenes yall
got that'd be cool I don't know if
there's ever been a proper steo
documentary maybe I don't know and
there's a really there's a really cool
angle that that we had talked about and
I think it would do really well and he
wanted to put it on YouTube too it's
just I get it I had zero subscribers I'm
sure people get emails all the time but
I I really believed that I could do it
and I I hope the Boogie is a good testim
to that yeah absolutely congratulations
I mean
wow really
cool and nice to connect with you thank
you for calling him that was a nice uh
Happy Crossing of paths
there yes and I got the Jimmy call out
of the way you know there was two birds
one stone that's true it's nice that
uh ah Jimmy what are we GNA do with him
man we can Bond over his
crazy yeah so I appreciate you guys
having me on it's fun so I just got a a
cough drops fragment in my throat it's a
great way to wrap up conversation you
good all right Mike take care fantastic
connecting and uh we we look forward to
to seeing more well done sir thank
you all right that's Mike CL Clum Clum
Clum it's Clum sorry Mike Clum
well that was a happy that happy
accident there yeah who do you think
would be like a really good subject for
a documentarian I have to think about it
a little bit more I think the
suggestions you threw out aren't bad um
I mean I would consider some options
outside the H3 sphere too just like some
internet personalities that have
remained mysterious you know like who
review
bra
um I I guess we don't know much about
review bra do we no yeah it is
interesting I think Dr Monson would be
amazing do you know who that is that's
the girl that like slammed dunks on no
Drew Monson uh was in like Shane videos
growing up but Drew was like 13 when
they met and he grew up on YouTube and
he's just he comes out with like these
videos of him just speaking into the
camera now and he he's talked about like
feeling lost on YouTube now so I think
it would be a super interesting doc oh
you know what well I guess this would be
stepping on Ian's toes a bit but I was
GNA say dax's flame but that's kind of
Ian's whole he's got a lot going on with
with him
right yeah that's the thing like you got
to think of one that nobody's really
gotten yet cuz Sho ni is a good
suggestion but he even pointed out that
even like Vice did a whole thing on him
I remember the vice thing was pretty
superficial yeah and it was it was a
long time ago now the thing is like
Boogie is not somebody that can commit
to anything so I would be worried if I
was him getting into a project with him
mhm despite it being certainly
amazing um let's see what else did we
not talk about did we talk about
everything you know what I would love to
see it's talked about Jeff talked about
Boogie we didn't talk about Ryan we
didn't talk about Ryan it is uh almost
five though yeah it's super late P you
know you know who would be a great
subject for a
documentary the eel pip
person right who we'll learn about on
Friday right
absolutely I do look forward to the eel
pit though it's pretty cool pretty
interesting pretty pretty
surprising we're get to it be a great
[Music]
segment I guess I can just do oh yeah so
I'll just give you guys a little glimpse
into the Ry R stuff we can talk about on
Friday Ela might
enjoy sharing her thoughts on it but
Ryan Kavanaugh announced he's making a a
a new podcast he actually put out a
press release about it and the title
what was the title again it was failure
failure right and that that to me is I
mean maybe a little on the nose I don't
know not very subtle we're going to
think you're joking Ryan Cav a former
relativity boss to host failure
podcast me and the boys this man
literally made a fake director's chair
what an assho stupid
podcast I didn't even notice wait wait
wait
wait who's getting
cancelled eat the
ready it's time to get
[Music]
cancelled
are you did already I did the same thing
angry I mean I'm just is that bad it's
pretty
generic okay I may have doxed Ryan kavan
on accident but we cut it
out it's not really a
dock 43,000 likes wow there's going to
be a lot of people watching this I'm
sure it is not the critic who counts not
the man who points out how the strong
man stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to those actually in the arena
shut the up Ryan this is just a
Roosevelt tweet I know I I know but like
dude get a grip but look at the bottom
the episode two it says with Brad the
bull
really Brad the bull Baskin thanks for
taking care of her wait if you're going
to start embracing the Goofs then let's
be friends stop suing me stop suing me
let's be friends I'll promote your pot
grab the B basket
I'll be a guess wasn't that his nickname
though no yeah we got it from we got it
from no
way it was like his Instagram was it
really no no Brad the bull was us I said
he's a bull because of the cuck
relationship that's what they call you
know no I'm questioning everything right
now no find it find an example there's
no way something like that no it was
always closing when we found him yeah
he's always closing do bull Brad the
bull is our
invention that's got to be a reference
to us well I'm reading an old Reddit
post that said uh Ethan said Brad was
built like a bull so they started
calling Brad the bull so yeah yeah I I
kind of remember what love is saying but
I guess we're wrong you coined it so
well it feels very natural it is it is
and so that's why I don't like people
trying to take my credit away for me you
know I totally get that in the wider
picture too this is him admitting he's a
cuck right
yeah let's zoom out for a second you're
right but I was going to say to Ryan
I'll even do your show I'll promote it I
mean listen the the picture the podcast
is called failure so clearly um it's
more about you than me but uh we'll make
it
work funny or maybe not yeah yeah maybe
not being too hard on yourself today I
need to yeah yeah you're good no needed
I I don't know if I don't know if I was
sounding arrogant that wasn't it I just
trying to diss him I see no head up
Queen your crown is
falling sounds like a toy podcast to me
true girl
Y what if it's good though what if it's
a hit he does know a lot about failure
like he's one of the world's foremost
experts and I may learn a thing or two
about failure from him I will definitely
be listening I'll tell you that we will
be listening but anyway the reason I
want to bring it up real fast is to tell
you guys that in our excitement for his
new project if you type his name Ryan
Kavanaugh into the search uh bar of
whatever browser you use scroll down um
here is oh man his website is ranking
pretty good here ours is number three
Ryan kav look like Harvey Weinstein uh
this is an important so if you go to
articles here you'll find that we
actually just put out a really good
press release about his
new
podcast which is you know putting his
name and the title of the pod podcast
and all the metadata is
certainly not to try to rank number one
for his show no and especially putting
it out before he launched his show it's
more about educating people that listen
this man's
qualified and I want to tell the
world you guys want to read the
article it's not too long in an
unexpected twist the former movie Mogul
Ryan Kavanaugh has announced a new
Venture into the podcasting sphere with
a show aptly named f failure this series
promises a deep dive into the missteps
and mishaps that have peppered
kavanagh's tumultuous T tumultuous
career offering a look at the
professional failure failures that are
as Grand as his once glamorous film
company relativity media that's that
seems fair thank you the premise of
failure offers an unfiltered exploration
of Kavanaugh's flops including the
spectacular downfall of a movie studio
and the fizzling hype of a social media
platform meant to rival Tik Tok well
hold on let's not jump to conclusions I
mean triller is still popping triller's
popping it's interesting yeah yeah
critics like popular YouTuber and
successful podcaster Ethan Klein and
that's not a slight at him I wasn't like
I'm successful like I If I had a show
about a podcast it would be called
success it's
interesting
um maybe okay so anyway CR critics like
popular YouTuber and pod e CL already
calling it a bizarre rebranding effort
suggesting that Ryan Kavanaugh is trying
to reshape His image from a privileged
hair with a mest touch in Reverse to a
relatable figure owning up to his
shortcomings the irony is not lost on
the audience of course the podcast title
seems to be a nod to his streak
Adventures that just did not hit the
mark in fact he was born to a wealthy uh
art collector a father who once faced
Scandal for dealing and counterfeit art
Ryan's Silver Spoon origin story is aost
focal point of the narrative Jos against
his professional
blunders because again he it's like you
don't understand what real failure is
because like you're still Rich right for
no
reason for no
reason while the podcast is an
intriguing Prospect skepticism remains
high detractors are already predicting
that failure might not live up to its
name continuing the pattern well I guess
wait would live up to it would yeah it
would live up to its name too much so
right continuing the pattern of kev's
venture is perhaps interesting and
concept yet deeply flawed in
execution whether it turns out to be
another notch in the belt of his
failures or becomes an unexpected hit
the entertainment world is watching
closely after the release date of
failure approaches the question on
everyone's mind is whether this podcast
will offer genuine Insight or simply be
another chapter in The Saga of kavanau
storied mishaps one thing is for certain
in the Land of Make Believe even a fail
faed attempt at Redemption can be as
compelling as any Hollywood
Blockbuster we will be watching and this
of course very closely uh from the mind
of chat GPT with some with some I
punched it up I punched it up sent it
over it didn't there were certain parts
that didn't quite work so I added the
thing about uh popular and successful
YouTuber yeah thank you for adding also
very crucial if you want to find this
article search why kav
failure and scroll scroll scroll scroll
till you find our website don't go
directly to the URL that's the slow way
go to Google Search ran kav failure so
let me do that oh it's the first one the
failure podcast oh okay okay never mind
oh how how nice keep doing that though
as you obviously see it that's the
fastest way to yeah love we got to
change the meta Title Here the title it
needs to be Ryan Kavanaugh the fular
podcast or it needs to have his name I
think that is what it currently is but
it's just it's not updated yeah it's
good that's good but yeah if you guys
want to read that again uh in your
private times in your free time CU there
is a lot to take in there and other
stuff to learn on the
website search Ryan cof failure and uh
click this link here I think did our
website crash very possible too much got
a lot of traffic right now too much
excitement looks like nothing was found
at this location love too much wine
sorry that happens
sometimes it's not a high budget project
well the thing is we talk about it every
every now and then so paying for very
expensive web hosting no you know who
cares Heavens no no will you go on if
you get invited if he drops his lawsuits
yeah I'll come I'll come but only
if he drops the lawsuit I'm not going to
go do his podcast if he's suing me that
would be a banger episode for Ryan kind
like worth it whatever you're like
hoping to gain which you're probably
going to lose anyways uh from suing
Ethan four times you could make up for
that by the revenue that you'll get from
a successful podcast thanks to e how do
you get a body like that Brad like and
he's a little he's like
middleaged like plus angry he's
middle-aged plus it looks like mhmh and
look at that body man wow wow wow wow
imagine getting railed by that
dudee h
I'm so fascinated by them embracing the
bow meme me too that's why I'm thinking
maybe there's a door open to close the
you know to bury the hatchet I really
hope so once I found that out I was just
like wait a minute there's something in
Dearing there it feels like I agree
because he's he's you know he's he's in
on the on the Goof which we love that
and by the way to be clear doesn't
really matter if you come in on the
website as long as you click it on
Google that's you know doesn't really
matter if it works or not oh it doesn't
no that doesn't need to be an
actual website oh it already has reviews
on Apple wait is it out already there's
previews there's okay yeah yeah yeah I
want to hear these with music they have
music though did you did we check them
no it just literally just like maybe 30
minutes ago love sent it to us and we're
having some trouble checking it look at
this you're going to have to like record
it or something looks like mill Gibson's
the p is he gonna sue you for playing
these teasers
could try it's even thinner than his
torous interference got five star
review got five stars oh
wow out yet look at this generic ass
looking do you think he's just been
watching our podcast and he's like I can
do that better yeah for sure he's like
these guys suck I can do it better
value' be very interesting to I I'm
personally looking forward to raid his
podcast when it comes out you know
fairly
listen let's let's do some copyright
checks on these and we can list them on
we'll we'll check in with it on Friday
along with the Y pit heel pit all right
guys listen Friday is going to be a
banger we got the
dream uh competition coming
out um I don't I was really thinking
that leftovers would happen tomorrow but
I think my throat is really sending me a
sign to abort it's interesting yeah when
uh so I'm going to take that as a sign I
definitely if even if there was no
Hiatus I don't think I would go tomorrow
it's just my my throat needs a day
off that's
fair try again next week I'm texting his
son right now because I don't want to
forget okay uh but thank you
guys thank y'all for watching it's been
a real fun episode action-packed episode
two great great Collins all three
including Jimmy wow that Jimmy mic
confrontation was spectacular wow that
was good riveting stuff I can't believe
Jimmy did that wait can wait cam totally
wait what I just a random book with the
same and who wrote this I don't
know I just found this from reverse
Google imag it's the same title and look
at the look at the art look at the cover
yeah oh it's Abel
simuk simuk simuk hold the phone
Ryan you're such a
dumbass like look how easy it was to
find this well that's not the same
that's not the same picture but it's
like obviously very very
similar silhouette of someone
celebrating uh at
Sunset yeah right failure maybe he just
like Googled that and
all right I don't know I I'm only
guessing I don't know anything about I
mean it looks extremely similar yeah the
same title it's very yeah very very
similar interesting good okay guys see
you on Friday thank you all so much
[Music]
k